foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
three months
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Daniel I need some help today I'm trying
to figure out how to do the show open do
you have any ideas well Tanya it really
depends on which Grandmaster you want to
invite into the studio to do the show
open for us there's a couple of options
there's the sort of generic high rated
Russian GM welcome to traffic very
pleasure to be here recommendation of
course there's someone more high rated
like Gary Kasparov you know welcome to
chess keep copy now it is you know real
pleasure to be here and reminded
something Corporal for 1984 but you can
also invite someone more modern like
Wesley so into the studio welcome
everybody to Majestic Cafe it's a real
pleasure to be here commentating and
covering the games of Jewel mustard
and Jordan
wow it is day four of the chess kit cup
welcome everyone
under one minute now for Hikaru and what
a move Holly razor look at him he's
biting his sweatshirt he doesn't know
what to do eight minutes and 59 seconds
beaten by one second could he have
swapped Queen's though oh are you in the
car saw it immediately
the Magnus has had no struggles against
a car over the board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he's trading him
oh my God
we see a reaction
is the winner of the chessable Masters
Fabiano caruana resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
it's a dance final day in the
elimination bracket three players remain
only one will go to get the popcorn
ready and enjoy the ride with us in the
studio Grandmaster David Howell PJ
Master James Canty
and Grandmaster Daniel larodeski
the youngest player in the field 18 year
old nordeback Abdu satrov has already
made his way to the Grand Final the big
question will be who will face him there
he has been Unstoppable David what has
impressed you the most about his run
hill what were Tanya nerves nordeback
just feels inhuman at this point he
never seems to get nervous even if his
clock is ticking down even if it's a
super complicated position he just seems
to outplay everyone really calmly his
Killer Instinct as well anytime he gets
a trance he seems to take it
he has been absolutely incredible and as
David pointed out in those critical time
scrambles keeping it all together and of
course today we will be seeing all the
action to decide who will be his
opponent in the Grand Final the first
match Fabiano caruana takes on jul now
Daniel on paper Fabi is such a big
favorite in that one but Jules he's
really shown that he can be a very
difficult opponent to beat here he is a
very difficult one and in all formats
and they're only over the board
encounter at the 2022 World Blitz
Championship Zuma start crushed Fabiana
caruana Fabby mentioned that he knows
Jules pretty well he's a teammate of his
and some European leagues and he is not
to be trifled he is a solid High 2600 GM
never an easy opponent
that's exactly the kind of chest that
we're expecting today a super close fire
Jules Musa took down
Dimitri colas in an Armageddon on a day
three now this event we've been seeing
big upsets but few Armageddon I want to
ask you James does that also reflect the
dynamic and decisive play by the players
absolutely of course I mean we don't
want to go to Army well they don't we
want Armageddon of course but they don't
want armaged in there so fabi's gonna
bring his best it's gonna be fabulous
Coe calculation Fabi and then Jules is
gonna bring his best that creativeness
to try to make it of course being an
underdog he's going to try his best
against the Phenom Fabi today are we
gonna see one today yes or no no oh
well we look forward to seeing these two
fight it out but it's not just in a
division one that we've been seeing all
the chess action it was a big day all
around and so many hits and misses
brilliancies all over take a look at all
the action from day three
decision
she's blundered the white king can now
creep forward oh my goodness
mating oh my goodness two seconds one
second he has to make there's no moves
unbelievable
takes the first win after being
completely lost this was a wild game
David
oh my gosh on the board look at Jordan's
face he realizes immediately
ran right into it because eventually a
piece is gonna have to take D1 it's
either the queen or the bishop both of
them defend the Knight motorbike Is Not
Gonna Miss This he solves these for
breakfast he sold these for breakfast
seven years ago
it's
not just a pawn it's the whole the
health of the position collapses
completely that Bishop on anyone is
pathetic and Jordan's like I missed one
again really just clinical play here all
right not the back
opposite color Bishop so maybe there's
still work to be done here good
technique to be shown or not the third
Pawn drop yes there's another one
bjordan Von forest does resign after
that last move as the third Pawn will
fall Jordan has a lot of enemies at his
door and he's navigating them so well
he's producing chance after chance he's
forcing Notre back to be accurate oh
wait you can hang it okay why is this a
blunder five and G4 oh my God five we
live we're going arm again possibly he's
about to make a move Queen A2 does trade
the Queens but a really bad end game and
he finds it Queen D4 super precise but
not the back she
Jordan got impatient he tried to force
the win he was a pawn up of two pawns up
he didn't need to go this direct and
there we have it not a bag of the Statue
of dicks
dick and the Jordan van Forest
what a dramatic match that was and this
means going into day four these are our
brackets and there we see that in fact
it was not the back of the satra who is
made so that the three players who are
in the losers bracket are down there he
took down Jules musad on day one then he
takes down Fabiano caruana and yesterday
his latest victim was Jordan van Forest
what a match that was we will be
starting with Fabiano Carana again Julie
Musa not the back of the satra of gets
the day off to get ready for the Grand
Final Daniel I want to ask you the match
that we witnessed between Jordan and uh
not abec yesterday did that surprise you
all the one move misses that happened
yeah I mean Jordan has been playing
excellent chess throughout this
tournament but Notre Beck is just so
unforgiving and Jordan that King's
Indian came so close to forcing an
Armageddon anything could have happened
there but like David pointed out
yesterday you got to beat these top guys
15 times right you beat them once they
get back up they keep producing chances
and your dinners didn't have that killer
instinct to finish the game off but all
credit to Notre back he's been a beast
and he's gonna be really hard to take
down in the Grand Final
it's going to be an exciting exciting
battle and of course it wasn't just big
tactics that we saw in division one but
there were also some surprising results
in the other two divisions
the players left it all on the boards
today as elimination loomed for some and
others the chance to make history in the
Champions chess tour as in division two
only two players are still undefeated
tomorrow new and yok trong sun will
battle Vladimir fedesev in the winners
bracket final basic draw new hand
advances oh my God they defeated Gregory
o'parin and round exudwani respectively
who will now drop down to play Dimitri
on draken and chakriar memajirov in the
losers bracket while each winner was
convincing particularly striking was
mamadierov's tactical and commanding
finish against La Quang Liam only one
more player remains undefeated in
division 3 of The Chess kid cup as Alan
pishot sent pentala Hare Krishna down to
the lower bracket to face David Navara
who is still alive and dazzled with the
move of the day the brilliant Queen G3
check he needed only a draw so he forced
it but the move was such a blow that he
was likely winning in the final position
David Navarro moves on with a
spectacular Queen sacrifice that might
be the move of the day everybody Queen
to G3 check
Simon can you just take a I can't wait I
can hook into a good selfie yep guys
looking good looking good have one name
yeah yeah it's really important to get a
good one because you've got to enter it
for the competition indeed the
competition what's the competition yes
sir and we've got a surprise for all of
you that will be the selfie competition
you've got to show us how you are
watching the chess kid cup post it on
Instagram use the hashtag Jazz Champs
and we will be revealing the best photos
and the winner at the end of the day I'm
gonna be sending in my entry Simon did
you get a good one are we winning that I
think it was pretty good yeah I think we
can do better but it will do I'm sure
it'll win No One's Gonna Get a better
picture out there oh we don't know if
we're gonna win or not but that will
definitely be a winner in division two
there are some big matchups coming up
and with ten thousand dollars and a
golden ticket to division one of the
next event on the line everything to
play for there is Tanya yeah it's
getting very tense now in every single
Division division one division two and
division three so let's have a look now
division two this is the Winner's
bracket so whoever wins this very
important match is guaranteed a place in
the final and if they win that they get
a place in division one which is a
really big reward now the losers bracket
there these guys have to fight a little
bit harder but you've got some massive
names there you've got Adrian mamajarov
and uh well there's every chance these
plays they've got to win that bracket
that match and then they've got to win
the next match as well to get into the
final but you know there's so much to
play for there Tanya love it and it's
been so impressive to watch photos here
just the last couple of months uh
everywhere I was the protest League
being in the winners Final in this one
what makes him so strong in these
formats well he's such a good player I
mean he's been doing so well on uh
chess.com he's been playing there he's
been practicing in the title Tuesday
events there's so many great events on
chess.com you can get your practice in
now and he's really been always at the
top so practice makes perfect and he's
homed his Blitz and Rapid skills to a
very high level
and it is also in division three that
the players have been showing some very
high level speed chess skills Simon big
action here as well there is this is a
really mouth-watering match between the
youngster Dennis lazovic who was born in
2006 and he's playing the veteran get a
campski remember this is the losers
bracket so if they lose any of these
players they are out but they need to
win these players to then go through and
face first of all I think Harry Krishna
are then at the end in the final already
pitch show so uh yeah mouth-watering
prospects there it's always good to see
David Navara in because he had that
fantastic uh finish as well in
yesterday's match which uh must have
given a lot of pleasure
win in the windows back
is the biggest ever season of the
Champions Chester with three divisions
and an exciting new format on the line a
big ticket to the big season final take
a look at the road map
each event in the Champions chest tour
is broken up into three divisions making
the CCT even bigger than ever before as
the best players in the world work to
win their division and progress to
higher divisions hopefully securing a
playoff spot big prize money and Tour
leaderboard points here's what's at
stake in the three divisions in each
event the winner of division three
receives five thousand dollars and
twenty tour points those with the most
tour points at season's end will secure
the wild card slots for the playoffs and
additional prize money the winner of
division two claims ten thousand dollars
fifty tour points and secures a coveted
slot in the next events division one
finally the winner of division one
receives thirty thousand dollars 150
tour points and a guaranteed spot in the
playoffs at the end the end year the
playoffs will include eight players that
have qualified either by winning
division one or by earning enough tour
points to claim one of the wild card
slots of these eight players four will
advance to the live finals in the
only one Champion will remain
five hundred thousand dollars on the
line and the players have to punch their
ticket Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura
have already made it to the season final
we will have a third entry at the end of
this chess kit cup but for now this is
the action that's coming up
on their last strike they face each
other the winner of this match will be
playing against Jordan van Forest later
today to decide the winner who plays
against not a back Abdul satrov in the
Grand Final and this is the format of
our elimination bracket the players will
be playing in a best of Two And if
that's a tie then it goes into the
Armageddon once again Daniel I I do feel
that this event the one thing we've been
missing out on is the Armageddon but
family being such a big favorite it's
going to be tough to get there for the
players yeah Fabi is a huge favorite but
there are only two games which means
there's very little margin for error and
because of the rapid time control high
probability of a blunder Jean mustard
might need a little bit of luck but if
he can win that first game I mean
there's only one chance to come back so
I think this is going to be a toss-up I
think the games are going to be close if
he can get Fabi low on time Fabi has
been anything but infallible in acute
time pressure let's see what the
Frenchman with two names is capable of
and they do you think because there are
only two games that the odds kind of
level out because anything can happen
with just little margin for error yeah
we've seen it throughout chess history
in knockout events it does get a bit
random often the best players don't
necessarily progress It's just about who
starts quicker who is fresher and who's
sharper in the first games and Fajr
musad he's gotta hope it's him because
as the match goes on if it does get down
to Armageddon I think his chances might
lessen we've seen it here Hikaru
Nakamura was knocked out alireza is out
so big upset uh keep happening and
that's exactly what the Champions
Chester is about giving the chance the
opportunity to some of the top Grand
masters of the world to fight it out
against the very best and we see that
Fabiano caruana is ready to go the
clocks are ticking he starts with the
white pieces what are we expecting uh
James on move one E4 I mean E4 for the
score that's what he liked to play very
he's very prepped I think for Jewels
here yeah there it is for my guys I see
you Fabi one time and then he's also
gonna have to probably mix it up here
yes something's true well he played this
last time and got a worse position in
the pets off here so let's see what he
goes with for this time wow in June
moussard playing the petrol of defense
against one of the world's leading
experts on the Petron this is a brave
stuff and uh we see this position before
actually several times this tournament
like having this Knight installed in the
center of the board almost symmetrical
but white with a bit more pressure on
the center and the first pause in the
game is taken by moussard here after
White's little Rook Shuffle there so I'm
going to be curious to see what he has
up his sleeve this has a reputation of
being Rock Solid for black oh is this
the line that happened in I hate to be
that guy oh is this Nakamura Vegeta's
2006. but I do remember this I think
from nepo's game against report in the
candidates there was a certain line
where white takes on B7 and then gets in
trouble on the king side of course for
me I don't really play this with either
color so all the positions look more or
less the same yeah I think I think you
might be right Daniel at least until the
last move or two yeah Bishop B3
definitely I think is uncommon yeah and
it does look a bit odd it looks a bit
unnatural to plant the bishop on the
Square where it's blocked in yes you're
developing but the white Bishop the
white darts go Bishop not necessarily
well placed and Joel takes the
opportunity to give white an iqp an
isolated Queen's Pawn uh what you make
of this development James yeah with the
iqp I mean it's very simple with the
planes don't trade pieces right so the
troll try to limit the trades here so I
think for Fabi you have sort of an
aggressive position so we're already
feeling pretty nice now of course you
wouldn't want to attack and use the pawn
the isolated Pawn as kind of upon lever
you move your pieces around it you play
around the pawn so the bishop maybe goes
to D3 now he may go to F1 there's like
probably the super GM move but Bishop D3
seems like the move that feels good just
to go back be on that diagonal maybe
there's some tactics with taking on e4
and moving the bishop or something like
that maybe even a knight G5 or some code
in some cases but I feel like White's
going to get some type of initiative
here if black is not careful plan is
very simple for black as well is to uh
blockade the pawn usually put a knight
in front of it so something like Knight
D5 at the right moment maybe by 986
Knight C7 Knight D5 or Knight F6 back to
D5 get this Knight to D5 control the
square in front of it and trade the
pieces that defend that pawn so plans
are quite simple here let's see what
Fabi does now
and Bobby there having a think about
where to retreat the bishop he's the
first one to take a thing and David I
want to ask you when you're playing a
game and you see that your opponent
slows down is that a sense of victory
that you got the first surprise in yes
and no it often uh means that I've made
a mistake if my opponent slows down I've
played a move that isn't the best that
they haven't studied before but uh here
I think Jewel clearly is in his
preparation you don't play a move a
really committal weakening move like B5
unless you're 100 sure you've kind of
worked out all the details afterwards so
jewel is in his preparation and if you
know what's going on and the opponent
stops that's a positive if you're kind
of guessing and then the opponent stops
it's like oh dear I've done something
I'm about to get punished but it
definitely feels like one of the more
positive cases here for Jewel maybe Fabi
though he's just kind of pausing
breathing in the fresh air look at the
air quality in his uh in his home office
right now all's good and he does take a
retreating with James you predicted this
just one minute of thought not too much
and uh playing a very sensible move
there so definitely pressure on black to
get pieces uh into the game you
mentioned that night maneuver looks nice
I tend to favor the isolated Queen's
Pawn in these types of positions but
Alpha grabs everything starts playful
and I see our chat they're really hoping
that this goes down to the wire they
want to see as much chests as possible
well the elimination bracket will be a
best of two so that would mean the score
would have to be level Fabiano caruana
on paper a big favorite in this match
against Jules musad but the trickery of
the Frenchmen we all know about it so
it's not going to be easy Bishop D3
potentially eyeing a queen Retreat as
well to put pressure along the diagonal
to build up the pressure along the pin
and now Jules are slowing down a bit
does that signify that perhaps his
preparation was not around The Retreat
on D3 but another one
perhaps but this looks like the most
natural move for white on the last turn
so slightly from using stuff there
definitely yeah of course it would be
more of a like okay there it is 96 so
you go for the idea he's gonna go 95
there but yeah I mean he did slow down a
little bit this is something you would
look at in prep Bishop D3 and Bishop F1
like will he go after that A3 though
Dania A3 oh he's stopping one route to
D5 but not the other one so night before
is impossible but Knight A6 can drop
back to C7 as you had indicated of
course that's less of an explosive move
the night before which would also tickle
the bishop on D3 that gives white a
Tempo but he can use to do a bunch of
things I mean the knight from B1 can
come out probably to D2 and challenge
Black's one of black stronger pieces on
e4 the queen from B3 can also drop back
to C2 either way I think Fabi is fabby's
play is going to revolve around
pressuring that Knight on e4 which does
look intimidating but is not defended by
any pawn so it can be pretty easily
attacked by a whole host of White's
pieces the Queen the Knight even the
dark squid Bishop could conceivably drop
back to C1 we could see Bishop C1 rather
than Bishop F1 and then the Knight is
seriously Under Fire
yeah interesting stuff maybe this is
this a threat if the Knight drops back
whoa okay Queen C2 and Bishop C1 I think
might actually be winning the game or
even Knight C3 tactically dang well we
should see once yeah maybe just Knight
C3 as you mentioned the secondary option
because uh just to show a point here
um this is actually a pin along the
diagonal pressure on the Knight and as
you said Daniel Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop intermediate move
you hit the queen next move you take
this Knight
wow huge blunder there but it's also the
most natural move and uh instead does
spot this of course and he keeps his
Bishop on G6 nice and protected so now
the same variation will be less scary
for example here black would safely be
able to take this Knight because uh his
Bishop is now protected on the G6 Square
my strategy there uh nice tactical
awareness from both players
Bishop G6 falling back just to make sure
that everything is under control on the
king side now Queen C2 you can simply
step back with the Knight or defend it
no more pins to answer and we see the
clocks happen leveled out it is time for
Fabi to think about completing
development so do you start with Knight
C3 here do you fall back with the queen
and what's the long-term plan in such
positions for white Daniel well you have
to identify the weaknesses
um obviously getting rid of the Knight
on e4 will allow you to operate more
effectively the C6 Pawn I think is in
the crosshairs Black's entire Pawn
construction on the queen side is rather
flimsy A4 might come at some point of
course that would weaken the B4 Square
so I wouldn't necessarily do that
immediately I would still consider
playing Queen C2 and Knight C3 get a
couple of minor pieces on the board and
ultimately pile up on that C6 Pawn Maybe
by bringing your Rook from A1 to C1
either way you have to get that knight
from B1 out in the next couple of moves
I just don't see a way around that
yeah makes sense Black's pieces have the
potential to be so active so why not
trade off one or two of them but uh Fabi
maybe he's looking for something more
ambitious I don't really see it right
now I don't really see too many options
one would be maybe jumping with white
knight to the edge of the board to try
and eliminate black slight squared
Bishop to at least create an imbalance
there uh get the bishop pair for example
but it looks like fabby's about to move
his body language his arm went away from
his face there it looks like he's about
to click something will he reveal to us
nothing obvious that's why it's so
tricky the Petrov just so solid there we
go definitely that's the move I was
liking the most because you do want that
imbalance here and what is holding the
Knight the E4 the bishop is right so if
we get rid of the bishop the Knight is
now on priest so you may have to maybe
move the Knight or play Rook E8 which
has given me some chances I feel more
comfortable putting my queen on C2 now
after I get rid of this bishop I can
also take it when I want to I don't have
to take it immediately but Knight G6 is
definitely coming so now the Knight will
be hanging so you have to do something
either move the Knight which I think
actually tactically blunders might upon
there there so if Knight F6 we actually
can maybe take Knight and Bishop or
Bishop Knight whichever way you want to
do it and we take due to the pen that we
have here so you might have to go
something like Rook E8 right and then
after rookie eight we could maybe take
on G6 or play Queen C2 first kind of
whatever you want but we do have an
imbalance yes I have an isolated Pawn
but you do two Jewels you do two on C6
and double pawns on the uh the G file
now definitely white is definitely
preferred here but uh still lots of play
left and we got a Biz repair for fobby
here so lots of questions to be answers
to
yeah I'm liking white I'm biased towards
the bishop pair I've got to admit but uh
Black's still relatively solid
and uh yeah I'm expecting him to go for
that variation you mentioned James it
feels like you can't Retreat the white
uh the black knight from the center
right now you just lose a pawn so you
have to keep it protected not too much
Choice what else could Jewel be thinking
about here
I don't see it and now five would be a
nice move except it's illegal oh that's
not on the table I wonder if he spotted
that one yeah I don't think so knowing
Jewels honestly is probably
it'll take him a couple minutes before
he realizes that too advanced to advance
oh Knight is for very direct play
Avi instead of thinking about
string development he is uh making his
Ambitions very clear and a good call
there by James Rook to eat it has to be
played otherwise you just end up losing
material and now we've got a minor piece
imbalance now very often when you've got
these weaknesses in the pawn structure
for white it's a D4 Pawn for black it's
the C6 Pawn it's about which side can
actually attack these weaknesses and we
see for black it's not so easy to build
pressure on the D4 Pawn meanwhile for
Fabi you can completely imagine a
doubling up of the major pieces on the C
file so is it fair to say that the C6
weakness is more vulnerable than the D4
weakness absolutely I think the c61 is
weaker of course it's a weakness if you
can attack it and it can be attacked in
fact C6 can be attacked by Queen C2
obviously we're going to move the Knight
somewhere and then play Maybe Rook a to
C1 if we're able to do that I do I don't
know where to put this Knight just yet
yeah just yet yet wow but of course we
will do want to put the Rook to see one
there and then we do have a light Square
Bishop that we can even reroute via E2
over to F3 to really attack we even have
the C5 Square unlocked so you might see
a potential B4 there so he goes Knight
C3 in fact in the live game there maybe
we'll see Queen takes after Knight takes
C3 maybe a B4 lock down to C5 Square
play Rook a to C1 reroute the Bishop
from the D3 over to F3 and then we
actually will have some real chances to
attack the weak C6 Pawn
yeah interesting he'd also well I would
at least be tempted to uh take on this
square with the pawn just because now
you have easy kind of levers to open up
the position very cute yeah Bishop Pat
here I think is uh far superior to
Black's selection of minor pieces so as
Azul I would be reluctant to take but
the if the options dropping back and
dropping a pawn then uh I think your
hand is forced Bishop takes Pawn here as
you pointed out James earlier just
utilizing this pin
again just uh direct play from Fabi but
quite effective place so far Daniel yeah
there's no other moves here for sure I'm
a little bit concerned that he's taking
his time
so it's it's Bishop takes G6 those types
of ideas that come out of nowhere very
easy to forget about but Jewel uh he
sees it he takes on C3 and good call
David BC which I also really like really
opens up all of these Pawn breaks on the
queen side it's not all about attacking
the C6 spawn you also have another
advantage in that your pieces are just
better placed you've got control of the
light squares once you play C4 and get
that Bishop on that diagonal you could
be pressuring the F7 Pawn this is the
kind of position someone like capablanca
would be really happy to have just a
long-term positional squeeze it's not
all about winning a pawn in the next
three or four moves just from a
long-term perspective White's position
is healthier fundamentally I think
fully agreed you have the bishop pair
you have maybe the more flexible Pawn
structure you have the access to the
pawn breaks black is purely reacting and
in chess especially at the top level you
don't want to be the one just kind of
reacting to your opponent's moves and
whoa big fella Flex real hard wow what a
move girl yeah I forgot that that threat
still existed Bishop takes Pawn on G6 so
black didn't have time to move the
Knight out the way but that black king
is not safe necessarily where it stands
right now and White's Pawn pushes that
you were mentioning yeah move smell it
has that smell of when you it's like
when I recycle my chicken sandwich in
the hotel that little hotel garbage
yesterday and I sat down at the death of
the following night and I'm like I need
to take this out of the room that's the
smell of King f8 right there not good
stinky chess
exactly you smell that Chad something's
wrong something's wrong with that move
now of course I mean it's really not
obvious yet it definitely is a strange
move of course but you can't really
exploit it just yet but I mean King on
f8 is definitely a weird one the same
weird one does step out of Bishop G6
though which is pretty obvious that was
the threat so maybe we just play A4 but
I do see Knight C7 here and I wasn't
able to create anything after that A4 90
C7 take take or even now in The Rook
beer you have to play Knight C7 right so
A4 Knight C7 and then we take
maybe we hold it but okay take I still
like white obviously here though yeah it
feels really Pleasant for white somehow
for example a position like this at some
point you'll build up extra pressure at
some point you might even just be able
to open things up even further for your
Bishops
yeah I'm loving it and a moment ago uh
we showed a variation I just want to
show this he played King f8 which has
that bad stench around it but if he had
recruited his Knight maybe this wasn't
winning a pawn bishop takes porn I just
realized that Bishop takes H2 might have
been possible
wow I was just trying to ask myself why
is the evaluation bar not reacted when
we put that variation on the board
earlier the whole idea is to trick
White's King forward and now you do have
a double attack so you can take back the
piece next move and actually you've
gained uh a lot here you take back the
piece with interest your knight will be
superior to the remaining white Bishop
now it's no longer paired up with its
light squared partner there so uh maybe
you're there just reacting a bit too
much and giving white the time now one
of these two must be played surely open
things up for the Bishops
thinking about that and trying to make
it work
what's wrong why doesn't it works
there's Bishop C5 and the D3 Bishop is
undefended but that has to be calculated
I mean D5 Bishop C5 Rook 8 D1 right it
gets very messy because if you can get
black to play C takes D5 the Bishop from
D3 when it takes B5 it's attacking
everything and then some you know the
queen and his brother are being attacked
and the rook in the night so I think
Fabi is devoting a share of his time
trying to calculate D5 because if a move
like that works out you don't want to
miss that opportunity because once black
plays Knight C7 it will be harder to
play that move and the other Pawn breaks
are going to be less effective as well
so this might be the moment to operate
wow D5 boom just explode open the center
stamping very very tempting you
basically have three tempting moves
right it's either this Pawn push open up
the white Rook you have this Pawn push
open up lines for your Bishops well this
one just open up the whole position but
which one to choose but a Russian
Schoolboy would play G3 here you know
that's slow improving more
just a bit blunt this bishop I feel like
that's a Fabby type of move actually if
he's not convinced by any of the pawn
breaks he might resort to one of these
improving moves and then later the
Russian Schoolboy will yeah the bishop
over time style yeah but as always
choosing a direct approach opening up
The Rook lines on the queen side A4 the
pawn break has arrived and great call
there David The Rook does go forward to
A5 putting pressure on the weak pawns
also eyeing that A7 Pawn with uh
doubling up on the A5 Black's got to
find his play on the king's side how
quickly can the Knight arrive after A6
96 Knight F4 is there a potential for
some trouble on King's side
I hate to break it to Joe moosad but I
don't think he's ever getting into that
white king as Daniel mentioned white can
just push a pawn up to G3 the black
Bishop is blocked the black Knight's
gonna take three or four moves to get
anywhere and I think the white Bishops
will always be able to cover any entry
squares later on but I don't know we'll
see it is rapid after all so uh maybe
long term in the future there might be
some counter play if white gets too
focused too distracted on the queen side
but meanwhile everything holding for
Jewel Jules can try like you know
tactics here in Knight D5 Knight F4
right Knight D5 first and then after 95
we got Knight F4 and obviously there's a
pin there and with the idea of Queen G4
yeah there's the Russian Schoolboy move
G3 but now we can't play Knight E5 so 95
the idea was to take on these two
obviously of Queen D5 so now that it's
not there we can't even get the Knight
to H3 or F3 we could try 96 and then
Knight G5 again using the pin on around
the E file um 96 95 over to maybe F3 or
A3 due to some light Square weaknesses
that will probably be covered after a
bishop F1 G2
yeah it would be a dream to get that
right James but often 96 maybe white
just doubles up and then that Bishop on
E3 the two square rule that we keep
talking about for all the chess kids out
there the bishop on E3 dominates that
Knight on E6 so you simply sidestep away
from the pin Rook A1 comes to mind you
put the pressure on the A6 spawn but
also a nice little tactic threatening
Bishop takes B5 and now that Knight on
E6 is uh dominated so you're just not in
time
yeah this is not a good night okay how
is the good night the good uh the good
night's good or it's very great place to
be in fact the pub here in uh Norway
shout out to the people at the good
night watching so this is definitely
cool but yeah 96 I mean it does tell you
how hard his position is to play right
now I mean can't play 96 my night's
terrible I can't go to E6 can't go to D5
I can't go to any other squares and then
this against the bishop pair this is
really rough even from a practical sense
I think it just says yeah you're fine
but this is a practical sense of stuff
for for Jules yeah you don't want to
overreact in positions like these so I
would consider moving The Rook from a to
d8 and keeping the Knight on C7 on a
defensive post to take the sting out of
White's Rook on A5 and kind of wait for
Fabi to put his cards on the table
because eventually Fabio will have to
make progress if he pushes H4 tries to
operate on the king side he weakens his
own King then Bishop takes G3 related
tactics become possible if the Rook on
E1 moves C4 of course is the most
tempting Pawn break but that opens up
the B file I know it's a far-fetched
comment but the Rook on A5 and The Rook
on E1 are on the same diagonal so I'd be
looking for tactics like BC and then
Rook V8 and Bishop B4 so you know black
can get in on this party as well if the
circumstances are right but let's see
what kind of defensive posture Jewels
adopts here yeah I completely agree here
you're kind of reacting again so just
Rook d8 all your pieces are ready they
are nicely uh nicely centralized here at
least for black all of uh your heavy
pieces here and uh yeah depending on
what what white does here you are ready
okay he goes for something similar to
what you mentioned there Daniel he's uh
clearly scared of this C4 break whoops
sorry my arrows he's clearly scared of
this C4 brick so he's ready for the
position to open up along the B file
fabby's gonna have to take a slower
approach now I wouldn't be surprised if
he does start re-routing his light Squad
Bishop maybe his uh Rooks double up or
at least maybe coordinate a bit better
somehow
really slow position again I would take
white but I don't know why I'm not sure
exactly what the next step is and there
we go aesthetically really nice move
there doubling up the white Rooks but
they're biting on kind of granite right
now that black Pawn on A6 nicely
defended by the Knight
bit of a waiting game maybe over the
next few moves a bit of maneuvering in
store
very dense middle game here it just
feels as a Fabiano Caron has done
everything right he's got the bishop
Perry he's doubled up on the A-line
targeting Black's weaknesses but what
next he did strike with A4 and look at
that Jules he uses the opportunity to
jump in with the queen give that Queen
one more move you want to arrive on F3
start threatening potential sacrifices
on that Bishop on E3 with that Rook
honey and the idea that we've been
mentioning come back with the bishop to
F1 place it on the long diagonal it
might be time for Fabi to do that yeah
there's also some crazy tactics in the
air can't yeah
Rook takes C3 uh and and you're
shattering the entire King side then
Queen takes G3 I would steer clear of
that and not touch over the 10-foot pole
David's showing that on the board right
now it's actually an objectively sound
tactic Eva bar approves for once in a
millennium and I suggest an idea and
then the queen keeps checking the king
along the third Rank and mopping up the
pawns as necessary
um even this and I think black's got at
least a perpetual and a long lasting
attack The Rook on A5 is so out of the
game here that really hurts White's
defensive chances so I would make a
defensive move Bishop F1 I like Tanya's
suggestion even a move like Queen B3
back to D1 I don't know who a queen
trade favors it's hard to say really
depends on fabi's mindset if he gets
scared here five minutes on the clock he
might play a move like that or if he's
in an aggressive mindset I don't really
know if you could meet fire with fire
here I think you need to make at least
one defensive move and his choice is
King G2
hey can you two on the board the king
slightly safer here you would think it's
on a light Square no checks around but
uh both of you have been mentioning here
the Knight potentially jumping in at
some point maybe now feels slightly
scary for the first time in this game
yeah maybe now 96 but I mean you have to
be sure because you're just giving up A6
like all right cool and uh you know
Bobby being a calculator literally
you're gonna have to uh be very careful
if you give up this point and it doesn't
work 86 looks cool but you know it's not
if it's not calculated it's not correct
right so it depends 96 looks fine but
you do have a calculator it's easier
said and done because we can just throw
the moves around but he has to actually
calculate this 96 Rook A6 and Knight F4
we just take it yeah it's hard to
envisage any real threats for black uh
over the next four or five moves that
white can't quickly neutralize so yeah
you've got to make sure you your attack
will work before you gamble and
sacrifice any pawns I don't see anything
active I've got to say for sure the
black queen is fighting a war all on her
own right now
no pieces for backup how crazy is F5
and yeah we live at five and we live
maybe he plays H3 we go Queen H5 or
something but yeah five F4 my guy uh
definitely we just might as well take it
to Fabi anyway I'm the underdog whatever
what do I have to lose and he said
everything and move this queen back to
D7 now I'd consider Bishop E2 Bishop O3
I really think that Bishop does belong
on the long diagonal F5 definitely a
move I'd play
yeah my opponent had less than you know
less than two minutes yeah yeah
definitely you predicted it Bishop E2
just improving the worst place piece
that Bishop looked nice and pretty but
it wasn't doing too much so uh Fabby is
rerouting it to rerouting it to uh
sorry router forget who I'm with here I
think you should bring your router for
the internet connection to improve
what's a router
now the black King's gone back to a
light Square back to safety on G8 this
thing back on G8 that's a funny move
it's really hard to know what next
though for Fabi again you ask yourself
you want C4 Dynamite there on the board
maybe that's the time
push forward
have we waited long enough
some action we're craving it we're
waiting for it you know I feel that it's
about to come right the tension is at an
all-time high with C4 you have to also
calculate lines what happens with the B
file opening up but this is fabi's
moment we see the valbar say he's got a
great position out of the opening C4
does feel like the break uh James what
would be your reaction would you let
that pawn live and survive and move down
the board or open it up and just be
ready for fire Ah that's a good question
if C4 happens yeah I might have to take
that C5 is quite annoying you got the
Bishops pointing I mean you have a past
Pawn but my idea for black is I just
want to get I also see like King H7 Rook
h a king G8 I'm always going for mate
always I don't care I'm sorry shout out
to grandfather towel right I mean this
is always go for me King H7 Rook ha
bring the king back but it just doesn't
work it's too slow right so he plays
Rook d8 I mean just to show you yeah
it's a fun idea right bring the king
back to G8 and try to bring Rook to the
H file speaking of Maine maybe white can
partake in that with h4h5
hello you're not the only one having fun
here most of these kick the queen out of
D7 now the queen has no infiltration
squares previously Queen H3 was a
possible response to this move I love it
I think Fabi is just sensing the right
moment to do everything in this game
he's playing on both sides of the board
so it's don't rule out C4 but you might
also go Rook H1 H5 h6h7 h8
yeah makes sense which one to go for
that's the key I would probably start
with moving this Rook maybe even to H1
and then kind of retreating this one
back first just to keep your options
open and uh really scary stuff visual to
deal with H5 coming on the board and
again two Bishops black locks the light
squared Bishop Black's King on a light
square is going to come under Fire later
in the game
beautiful play by Fabi Rook H1 yeah
offering a queen trade he is uh afraid
of that attack that you guys were
talking about with the H Pawn marching
down the board and officer Queen trade
but this means if Fabi accepts it black
spawn structure would be one of the most
terrible Bond structures I've ever seen
what fun structure yeah after F takes C6
it's very tempting but I'm equally
tempted by the prospect of keeping the
Queens making a move like Queen D1 then
Knight D5 is possible for the first time
since the dinosaurs roamed the Earth but
95 isn't all that dangerous the bishop
can drop back to D2 and it really
depends on fabi's mindset Queen takes C6
Queen D1 you don't want to think too
much in these moments and he decides to
go into the end game can't blame him
yeah yeah Queens are often backward porn
doubled isolated pawns isolated Pawn in
the center ugly stuff Bishop G5 the last
move to land on the board I think Fabi
might start going for this Pawn you
might start going for the other one
instead so many weaknesses it's hard to
imagine black surviving this one and uh
yeah Bishop G4 on tap now the rook and
centralized
feels like one-way traffic the same game
any chance of saving this we think
visual
perhaps the black just had one more move
jump in with that Knight to D5 start
targeting White's weakness on C3 so
there are some ideas that Jules has some
targets for black hair as well and
perhaps white doesn't have all the time
in the world to just stay sell you've
got to go for those pawns this very
moment but how do you do it it's not
super clear Bishop G4 King F7 Maybe
yes he can hold for now okay Fabby
swings the other way he's maybe
threatening or hinting that he might
push the C Pawn also just defending any
potential weaknesses that white sea Pawn
that The Rook has kind of sat behind now
the only potential weakness in White's
camp yeah he's just saying okay I'm
gonna maintain the attention and what
next for black I think as you say
Italian Black's King might just step out
just to defend a few pawns preemptively
but what next Black is totally stuck
Black's Knight is Frozen where it is
just defending the black A6 Pawn Black's
Bishop has nowhere to go blacks Rooks
stuck behind the Knight
everything's wrong with Black's position
yeah everything's wrong here I mean as
you mentioned this Knight got there what
move ago like when did the Knight get to
C7 and they're still on C7 right so it's
a really rough position you're also in
an open position with the Bishops on the
board I have both of them you have a
weak Pawn structure practically this is
not good at all for black and you have
to have Precision all the way throughout
but time is getting low anything happens
when time gets low so I think you know
Jewel's best bet is to you know hold
hope for the time to get low create some
complications as we see you order to do
a very good job of doing that type of
thing too as well and then see what
happens there is still not over you have
a C3 Pawn that is weak that Bobby does
right and if that falls or you make some
problems with C3 D4 could fall as well
we get pawns on the same side we got
some good drawing chances there
yeah and I'm probably down to about
three minutes but Jules the one who's
got less time on the clock and a
difficult end game to defend it's going
to be an uphill task for the French
Grand Master the aim is to get that
Knight to D5 but A6 being weak perhaps
he's thinking about a potential rock
cliff to B6 try and hold that sixth rank
all the weaknesses for black are on the
sixth rank put one of your Rooks there
and get that Knight out of C7 he's
taking two minutes on this move which
tells me he's calculating something
maybe it's B4 I don't believe in that
move but he might feel that the
situation has gotten to that point of
desperation if I had to make a move
quickly I'd propose Bishop f8 to D6 we
were to prevent Bishop F4 we were
talking about King F7 so it really
depends on how desperate he thinks he is
but he is digging himself into a big
hole over two minutes spend on this move
I think he's calculating either Knight
D5 or B4 trying to make sense of it and
he resorts to a slow move so he's just
spent a lot of time he's got 90 seconds
left this is going to be a gargantuan
task hold this position against Fabby
and white can build up white could also
consider pushing forward with C4 in the
near future I don't know whether you
want to start going for some of these
pawns for example maybe you bring your
Bishop to a slightly more kind of
cohesive square with the rest of your
pieces but either way Abby's in charge
one minute up on the clock and look at
the evaluation bar considering that it's
level material Level pieces and pawns on
the board the fact the computer thinks
it's completely winning for white at
this point says it all white must have
something if not direct then at least
long term while black is pretty much
Frozen unable to find an active plan
I would love him
with use for Abby and this is why C4
coming in and if you don't take the pawn
advances down to the board you've got to
do it and now there's a lot of pressure
on the C file Rook is coming to C6 so
the pawn is going to start falling one
by one you could just hit the button
here man hit the button that's the
resign when we meet here this is Gross
Alaska oh everything's full it's been
such a smooth game by Fabi honestly he
hasn't made any mistakes so far wow it's
hard to pinpoint any big mistakes from
Jewel as well just no big blunders just
maybe one or two small inaccuracies
maybe losing a bit of time with the
black queen earlier
feels like a masterclass from Fabi this
is strategic dominance this is just a
strategically winning position no
tactics nothing flashy old Manchester's
I like to say just slowly accumulate the
small positional advantages and they
tend to count later on
have you got the bishop pair he's got
the better Pawn structure everything now
how does he finish that's the hardest
thing in chess yeah finishing off these
types of positions well Rook C6 comes to
mind to try to guarantee uh the F4
Square for a White's Bishop Bishop B4
you can drop the Rook maybe even to A2
in order to prepare Rook a to C2 even
though Rook A4 is very tempting to keep
the bishop under pressure at this point
there's usually a lot of options many
roads lead to Rome you just want to keep
your foot on the gas pedal I think black
might just be a couple of moves away
from having to resign here push the
button push the button yeah 30 seconds
as well just to find a way to continue
here to actually guarantee that you
won't lose a piece because I would be
scared that one of the black two uh
minor pieces here is about to get
captured or trapped yeah I don't know
I'm very surprised that uh jules's
Choice here the Petrov didn't work
yesterday as well for him I mean it just
didn't work and she just chose to go for
it again of course you'd like to stick
to your guns but definitely something
maybe more creative from him or
something a little bit they gave him
more chances as opposed to trying to
play Super solid and playing the Petrov
against a Petrov player right who was a
made a statement with the Petro from
himself Fabiano that is so pretty rough
but at the end of the day probably all
that doctors
B5 is the first question oh wow wow
at all I did not see that either yeah
it's probably because it's bad no I
think it's actually the best move quite
possibly I mean you could also take on
A6 here if you want to play continue an
old Manchester style Fabi is definitely
calculating works xp5 I think yeah you
could win the A6 pawn pawn up for free
but at least Black's pieces are active
like we have to put this on the board
Tanya will it happen will Fabi go for
this move a bit of calculation needed
Rook takes Knight removing the defender
of this bishop if the Rook is captured
two Bishops against a rook this is gonna
be winning oh boy let's go well spotted
and this is actually happening just to
show the other variation the more
complicated one maybe after Rook takes
Rook Rook takes Rook takes takes takes
takes and after this white Rook has
captured this one hangs white has an
extra piece so let's catch back up with
the game
it's domination here again look at these
Bishops this bishop is coming into E5
this black king is going to get mated
yes now but it shouldn't be quick enough
this is B3 pawn and that can get tricky
Fabi has to keep that under control
Jules 20 seconds he's got to keep the
clock under control how dangerous is the
B Pawn it varied I mean it's two moves
away from not being a bee Pawn anymore
let me tell you that now Fabby with
Bishop before he's trying to use tactics
meeting fire with fire but where is the
mating construction you don't want to go
Bish actually you might want to go
Bishop B1 and meet Rook C1 with the
bishop takes G6 he takes immediately B1
equals Queen is gonna happen you might
just want to take on G7 then recapture
the queen and say I've got 600 past
spawns and send the closest one the H
Pawn down the board to promotion all
right I love the everything about the
way Fabi has converted this Advantage
literally everything four seconds or
juice there we go
G7 and H5 simple as that H5 and we live
yikes the Strategic Masterpiece by Fabi
just never give any chance at all to
choose suffocating conversion by Fabi
h6h7 h8 H9
Jill's gonna resign here
big deal
a couple of checks that's then he'll
throw in that towel raise the White Flag
if this one is over beautiful technique
but I want to point out one thing I was
gonna say Rook B3 King E4 rookie one is
made but even that doesn't work because
there's an F4 Square wow eight seven on
the board h8 is coming and this is game
over Jose does resign Fabiana Karana
playing a positional Masterpiece one
where it's hard to even point out where
Jewels went wrong is this Fabi at his
best Daniel this is the Fabi who got
seven out of seven in the same field cup
that was an incredible game he obviously
was going through a tough stage in his
chess career with his candidates
performance but Fabi is back he's fresh
off a tournament Victory this is the
positionally suffocating Fabby with
great opening preparation good
improvisation after Jewels who threw
some prep at him everything about that
game screened super Grand Master to me
let's see if he can finish it off by
holding with the black pieces
Perfection there by fabulous Fabi and
David what was the coolest moment in the
game for you several cool moments just
an instructive game in general strategy
combined with tactics from Fabiano
carawana it was this position after
Knight to B5 that Tania spotted a quick
tactic and Fabi enacted it on the board
Rook takes Knight removing the defender
of this bishop did win material and
later on if we fast forward a few moves
we saw the black porn running down the
board but he did not panic the white
Bishop's so strong look at their power
and uh here we saw Fabi simply cash in
with some pawns and it was indeed Harry
the H porn that ran up the board and won
the game great game from Fabi
I was some amazing chests that we saw
and it's going to be a tough task for
Jules Musa going into the final rapid
game of this best of two match Fabiano
caruana with the white pieces a sweeping
Victory there super convincing chess
wins the first game Jules has to win on
demand to take it to Armageddon but he
does talk with the white pieces we will
be back with all the chest kid action
for that final game after the switch
break
thank you
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only
game-changing Innovations from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play our history defines us
inspires us and pushes us into the
future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
foreign
[Music]
Focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space shifting your state with
every breath
find your air of clarity now
it was a picture buffer game by Fabiano
caruana and don't forget to send us your
pictures of how you are watching the
chess kid cup and we will reveal the
best photos and the winner at the end of
the day and you will win the Athens wave
plus device to make sure that you've got
all the fresh air you need to play the
best chess the one player who needs to
get some fresh chess on the board It's
gotta Bejeweled what does he do next oh
yeah that's a good question of course
you're playing Fabiano caruana okay so
with that being said I mean you might
drop you know what I mean so it's tough
for Jules here he has the white pieces
play your game right play what you're
used to playing maybe try to take them
on a book a little bit because Bobby's
prep for really everything so try to
make throw something out and be a little
bit creative I hope for the best starts
with the white PC
you can expect from
the well he tends he tends to be very
loyal to one E4 he's extremely dangerous
with why extremely well prepared and he
always has these small little ideas to
create imbalances so if he does get a
chance against Fabi to maybe attack I
think he needs to take it that first
game Fabi has shown that he's dominant
when it comes to the strategy she'll
need something a bit more spicy there
and it's so difficult to face that game
after you're done with that it's not a
tactical game you just feel like you've
been outplayed Daniel does that make it
harder extremely I mean by all means you
just have this debilitating Sensation
that Fabi is just infallible he didn't
make a single inaccuracy in that game
that was almost perfect
and uh Jules I think an Italian is
pretty likely that's what he's played
against me in a lot of our Blitz Games
but in the Italian against Fabby man
this guy has no holes in his opening
repertoire it'll be a very tall order
but Joel did win their game with the
white pieces in the 2022 World the
championship so I think he's feeling
confident let's see what he can throw at
Fabby in the opening 184 and we saw one
E5 are we gonna see a Spanish or an
Italian by Jewel the Spanish might
invite the Berlin
oh and the fact that he's pausing
already just in week three
it is the Spanish and okay Mainline
Spanish we saw Jewel employed this
yesterday a couple of times against
Dimitri collards that was an open
variation of the Spanish this time more
traditional more classical Waters and uh
what is he gonna try yeah again how do
you get Fabby out of this fabby's like
one of the leading experts in chess
history on the Roy Lopez so again
walking to the opponent's home territory
walking into their comfort zone I'm not
sure it's uh the strategy I would advise
but maybe Joel can make it work
what does he have upper sleeve here D3 a
slower system more positional system
I don't know though it just feels like
fabulous in his comfort zone yeah
there's no tricks there's no I mean this
is one opening played in study to you
know Oblivion right since the history of
Chess like you everyone knows here
you've got h3c3 A4 rookie one all these
moves can be played here it's gonna be
they call it what the Spanish torture
right which means they're going to be
playing this for a long time lots of
ways to go for both sides here it's
gonna be tough it's definitely a tough
one I think you probably should have
went something a little bit more open
something a little bit more aggressive
but we will see what happens I mean he
probably likes Roy from both sides in
fact so we'll see what happens here yeah
and at least if you're going to play the
Spanish with white uh you should aim to
get the first 15 20 moves on the board
instantly you'll spent nearly one minute
on that last move meaning he's kind of
freestyling Daniel yeah and you can
freestyle in the D3 variation there was
a time when the D3 Roy was considered a
sideline it was considered not really in
figure to the main c3h3d4 line but
something you would play if you wanted
to avoid the theory but you know that
was back in the days when I don't know
California real estate was cheap that
was like 60s nowadays it's considered
just as mainstream as the D4 line yeah I
mean Knight bd2 Knight F1 you can
basically make a living and this Line's
just playing regular real Lopez moves
but you're not going to get an advantage
Fabi he definitely knows the right setup
here for black and you can see as he
continues to play quickly rookie 8 and
Bishop f8 is likely H6 both sides just
making the standard moves that the
textbooks kind of recommend in these
types of positions yeah I'm going to be
taking notes for sure I always struggle
with black on the kind of in terms of
plans here setups what to go for and
everyone knows Fabi is a big expert here
so whatever he plays now you can
guarantee I'm going to be copying in
future games but okay opening the center
as you'll normally you see white prepare
this uh with a couple more moves but uh
instantly going for this what do we
think is this just uh kind of impatience
to get some action going I used to play
this from both sides actually too as
well so D4 is a common move actually
black plays clean C7 here most times
what I've seen this like older Theory
but it's still played today but saw Sam
saving recently had a game with Queen C7
here Queen C7 is doable Knight C6 you
come back with the Knight as well it's
very easy play for both sides I mean
black does go Queen C7 maybe bishop of a
G6 Bishop G7 later bring the Knight back
around you hope for a D5 the Knight
sometimes ends up back on B8 and you
rewrite route it I mean it's so slow
like Spanish torture it really is a slow
game here um you're not gonna get a lot
especially against Fabi right now I just
don't think he's gonna have any real
chances until weigh later in the game
where a lot of these even fizzle out to
draws from there which is not going to
help Jules
oh and uh if he gets the option do you
think he's going to try and block the
center for example uh James there you
mentioned Queen C7 being one of the most
likely moves in this position is he
going to block the center just to
guarantee in a must-win situation that
all the pieces remain on the board
um this one doesn't necessarily give
white an objective Advantage but it
ensures that it's going to be a really
tense battle later on do you think
fabi's going to I was just about to say
do you think he's gonna kind of ensure
that doesn't happen by opening up the
center and he has gone for that so
isolated Pawn for black but this Pawn is
not necessarily weaker than white
Central Pawn big Target in the middle
here that that can gang up against
yeah decision White's position is
preferable generally uh because of the
superior central control but these
positions have a very high dry tendency
if black can get D6 D5 to work and
liquidate the remaining Pawns in the
center you often see essentially all of
the Pieces come off along those open
files and from a rapid play perspective
I think this is a much easier position
for black to play than the one you
indicated previously with the close
Center because they're white attacks on
the king side and that's really never
fun Fabi likely to play Bishop B7 might
drop his knight from A5 back to C6 or
forward towards C4 ultimately black is
going to try to find the perfect moment
to strike in the center with D5 if you
do it prematurely of course you allow
white to play E5 and you know there will
be hell to pay as this Pawn rushes up
the board
yeah this is a nightmare for black
especially if you're forced to retreat
suddenly there'll be mating attacks all
over the place White's Queen can step
forward and yeah this black king will
hate these developments so Fabi has to
time it correctly but uh he's fine for
now going back to the game position
definitely don't play this move unless
you're 100 sure it's going to work
and G6 on the board again blocking that
diagonal that we just showed just in
case and stopping any Knights entering
the F5 Square and also locating that G7
Square maybe at some point that Bishop
from f8 for Fabi will arrive on this
long diagonal and try and create some
player on the queen side uh this looks
like an opening outcome that Fabi should
be happy with but the fact that all the
pieces are on the board there's still
everything to play for for white with no
simplifications this is perhaps Jules
best chance to try to get some play yeah
it's not a bad position it really
depends on whether he can generate play
in the center because fabby's got a
couple of very easy moves you pointed
out Bishop G7 Tanya Bishop B7 as I said
earlier we can coordinate The Rook so
there's a lot of low hanging fruit to
peek here for black you're not going to
win this by playing a waiting game you
need some sort of active plan I always
struggle in these positions with white
to find that active plan I like Bishop
D2 though by Jules just a regular
developing move can send that Bishop
over to the long diagonal with Bishop to
do to C3 which will likely be his
response to Knight C4
yeah interesting because uh it feels
like that Bishop might get neutralized
down here I'm not so sure about this one
I've got to say uh just to show the idea
you mentioned Knight to C4 this is
definitely going to be met by Bishop to
C3 but then the black Bishop lands on
this diagonal as well is this helping
White
yeah maybe not I mean maybe it is I'm
just not sure what next that's the big
question yeah no that's the problem you
can play B3 and Chase the night out of
C4 no problem it can jump back to E5
it's got plenty of plenty of options
yeah that gets one or two more moves the
bishop Out The Rook to C8 it feels like
he's healthy enough
very difficult difficult for Jewels here
but uh Fabi not reacting instantly I
guess this position is still very
balanced objectively so anything can
happen a bit later on but uh yeah it's
probably will be once the clock start to
tick down that Jordan is going to really
make try and make his Mark gonna try and
confuse his opponent
I might go for a bishop B7 too as well
quite quickly but then AC4 definitely is
a great idea there just puts a knight
back around because the Knight is on the
rim night on the room is dim usually you
do have to move this Knight back in the
game at some point usually you take this
time usually now before they stop you
with a B3 anyway the nice C4 looks good
right AC 495 ic49 B6
plenty of choice at least for black and
that's a good sign for Fabi but that's
the thing right David we need to find
plenty of choices for wine because
there's Jules musad who is trailing the
match he needs to win to level the score
and let's say we have spoken about all
these uh trumps that are in fabi's
position the Knight can come to the
center of the board can be on C4 the
bishop placed on the nice long diagonal
but if we had to try and come up with a
plan for white to create an imbalance
from this position where do you see his
chances
oh difficult question can I pass
yeah I'm passing as well I abstain now
it's not difficult it is with all the
grand Masters in the studio they are not
able to find a good plan for Jules musad
but he needs to find it and he needs to
do it in just 12 minutes and what you
need to do is send us in your photos of
how you are watching the Chaska cup and
you could win the atings black wave plus
device and just to know how important
good fresh air is for your chest take a
look at fabi's air quality we saw that
earlier uh super good quality super good
chest from him today and a nice move by
Jules Bishop C3 also keeping up his
chest quality uh making sure that that
Bishop on G7 is challenged can he try to
build pressure on that D file I feel
like that's the only weakness I see for
Fabi that D6 spawn can you try and
double up and create something there
you would love to I guess it just takes
a few moves and in the meantime Fabi of
course will have his say too uh we are
expecting maybe this Knight to jump in
at some point you don't necessarily need
to rush uh Bishop to B7 for example uh
okay the evaluation bar reacts
imagine the night landing with a
sacrifice and okay the bar doesn't react
that much you could imagine that
certainly some danger here for black and
the black king even at the cost of a
white knight Fabi decides okay I don't
want to move my Bishop off this diagonal
just yet he brings his Bishop to attack
the White Queen interesting because a
lot of uh the viewers at home a lot of
the chess kits out there might be
thinking oh I can just push a pawn and
gain time against this bishop and yes
you can maybe he will assume aside but
uh Fabi will just drop back and argue
that actually the white King has
suffered from this transition white has
gained a move in effect black has spent
two moves with the bishop but now this
diagonal is a bit vulnerable and the
dark squares around the white king will
eternally be weak what do we think of
that decision
Bishop G4 is a provocative move it
definitely is you know of course you
make this movie like oh exactly you just
play F3 but then you do weaken all the
dark squares there which okay they are
weak but they're not super weak because
it is defended with the bishop on C3 you
can maybe go King H1 in many cases too
as well right and we also gain a Tempo
there which gained some time we also can
stop any Knight G4 stuff anything
swinging into G4 at any point but it
also Cuts your queen off it's like pros
and cons to both because you eventually
maybe wanted to move the queen up to F3
play F5 stuff like that he chooses Queen
D3 nice option D3 instead but maybe this
queen will be vulnerable later to some
hits for example the Knight coming to E5
um I think he might be going for your
idea long term Tanya you mentioned for
example a position like this if we can
never kick this bishop away which we
might try and do in the next few moves
then you can bring your Rook to the
center and go for this weak backward
Pawn but it's just so tense in the
middle of the board look at this
diagonal Bishop Knight Knight Bishop
it's just all the tension there and
Something's Gonna explode at some point
such heavy pieces but I like the juices
withstood the temptation to play F3
because you want to kick the bishop away
with H3 to avoid weakening the Integrity
of your kingside Pawn structure then go
Rook D1 so we've been singing the
phrases of Black's piece coordination
but yes the D6 Pawn is a weakness don't
forget about that D5 Pawn break which
could come after Black's Knight lands on
C4 because the E5 square is then well
controlled there's a ton of calculation
to do in these types of positions this
just might come down to who calculates
better Fabi choose trying to choose the
perfect moment to run that knight from
A5 into the center of the board that
perfect moment might be now but he's got
plenty of Alternatives Queen B6 Rook C8
it's always I always struggle when
there's like three or four equivalent
looking moves which one do you choose so
hard to predict the direction that this
game is going to take
and Rapid chess you just have to trust
your instincts right you also mentioned
there the word calculation comes down to
kind of uh who's going to calculate
better James you know who's the boss at
calculation here CLE baby calculation
over everything Fabi is definitely a
human calculator as well right uh he has
a quote that I actually use a lot of
this says yeah most players are have
Universal Styles right but they're made
the only thing that really separates
them is the calculation so that's very
important to have that calculation work
and of course Fabi leading from the
front there with that quote definitely
whoever calculates better in this game
for sure we'll take it Queen B6
interesting move here
and what you mentioned James about
calculation I just want to push that a
little bit because Fabi we know he is
one of the absolute best players when it
comes to calculation is just the
strongest tool that you can possess in
chess is to be a good calculator David
what would you advise to all the chess
kids out there how can they improve
their calculation well there's a few
ways firstly always analyze your games
uh especially with Coach afterwards
they'll show you what you missed
especially when it comes to those
forcing moves we talk about checks
captures and threats a lot and it sounds
basic but if you look in that order if
you do a scan of the checks capture the
threats you'll very rarely miss a tactic
for yourself or for your opponent second
thing just puzzles chess.com go and
check out some puzzles I do them as
regularly as I can recently I've been
slacking a bit and I've noticed my
calculation has dropped so I think a
good tool out there a quick a free tool
as well just to practice your time I've
been cycling for about 13 years but your
taxes don't suffer down here yeah yeah I
don't know about that but yeah you do
have to solve very consistently and in
my experience it's most people who say
ah you know I solve I do puzzle rush I'm
grinding and nothing improves you
actually go into their history and it
turns out they've solved five puzzles a
week that's not going to cut it you know
if you really want to improve your
tactics elevated to a different level
you need to be super consistent and you
just got to force yourself
so put in those R's for the puzzle rush
and get your tactics going and your
calculation to the best of its ability
we see the very best players in the
world today modern chess is all about
those concrete lines and it is the
fastest way to get those ELO points
going now Knight B3 has been played it
is a first minor piece trade offered
rejected by uh Fabiano caruana jumping
in with that Knight to C4 always heading
in over to that E5 Square again white
has to push that Bishop out of G4 you
really need a rook on D1 and Daniel as
you pointed out you want to do it with
the H Bond not to compromise your king
side the bishop falls back are we
expecting The Rook to go over to D1 yeah
but black can meet that with Rook a to
d8 that Knight on C4 is so firmly
entrenched it can't be kicked away
because White's Knight is occupying the
B3 Square Fabi drops the bishop back to
D7 interesting this tells me that he
wants to take this thing out of a move
like Knight to D4 and he doesn't even
have to play Rook d8 because Rook D1
doesn't pose a threat as long as the
night remains entrenched on C4 the
Bishop from D7 could be redeployed to C6
to pressure the E4 pawn it seems to me
maybe white has a tiny pull objectively
but it seems to me that Fabi has
everything under control here right now
there's just a sense in which he knows
what he's doing and everything's
everything is under control here for
black
yeah it feels that way and when we talk
about players being an expert in a
certain opening it's not just because
they memorized the first 10 15 moves
it's because they know where the pieces
belong all the plans how to react if
your opponent chooses certain ideas and
you know we expect white to slide into
the center he goes for something
different attacking the black queen
kicking her back somewhere but uh I'm
not sure how this improves the white
position at least it worsens the
position of the black queen perhaps I
think he wants to go for more with a F4
eventually here when you usually usually
you'll see this in like it has a
philadelph
somehow like it feels like it's Villa
door-like you know where you play H3 and
in the Philadelphia fence you actually
do play F4 you put the Rook on the D
file many cases so F4 is quite possible
it does look aggressive enough and we
want to play E5 at some point we want
our chances Rook a to D1 is just natural
though very natural move but F4 is
hinting we couldn't play it before
obviously because Queen on B6 Bishop D4
kicks it back there's no Rook coming to
d8 now you can't complete all the way
development works are disconnected
temporarily so nice move I think The
Rook a to D1 and F4 are definitely some
huge possibilities we get F4 in we may
be able to get E5 in due to some tactics
at some point you got to time it
correctly but yeah we have some chances
definitely from White
hmm do you think he's going to do it now
push forward the F Pawn signal his
aggression in the game I mean I don't
see why we can't you have to be careful
because you are playing Fabi like yes
it's scary like F4 and then you
immediately lose like of course because
it's probably what F4 def there it is
come on Jules now of course H5 him fire
with fire let's go F4 so about E5 after
that
F4 E5 takes takes E6 nope doesn't work
yet oh it's close we're trying to open
up everything okay
so just to show some ideas you guys are
mentioning that okay he plays Rook C8 I
really liked your H5 Daniel I must say
just to kick away this night from the
protection of the E4 square instead he
delays this one just uh improves his
worst piece that Rook was asleep on C8
and James you're mentioning this
breakthrough is white ready that's the
question do you have to prepare it maybe
by uh bring the Rook across if you push
now then uh it might well backfire the
Black Knight I think it's safe to the
center and this week's sporting is uh
just getting in the way for white you're
not breaking through on this diagonal so
no attack yet if you think it works like
shifted like if they were just Rook F1
and then the other Rook on E1 then you
have second possibilities on F7 in that
position but it's you know one move at a
time you can't do both works right now I
can't go Rook F1 anyone at the same time
and that will give us more chances here
so he does have to prep it you might see
something like Rook F1 but that is
slow it's definitely slow
yeah it's slow and if you just uh
improve your pieces Fabi again does have
the option later on of pushing this Pawn
kicking away the Knight and this one
okay he's pushed his Rook to E2 looking
a bit superficial with that move but
it's about to explode this feels like
the Calm before the very very strong
storm
wow rokito is definitely not a move that
many of us would have predicted he wants
to get that A1 Rook perhaps to the f
file that James you were pointing out to
get E5 in but my Spidey senses are
tingling here with the queen and the
Rook lined up is it crazy to imagine an
idea like the beep on stepping up the
board one square and actually that B5
Square being taken over by that Bishop
on D7 and start threatening a skewer
perhaps I love that idea and all of it
boils down to the fact that the E5 Pawn
break it's potentially dangerous but it
also creates a lot of problems in
White's territory so I think Fabi is
just fundamentally not afraid of what
Jules has to offer in the center which
gives him the time to build up his own
initiative on the queen side I love B4
and Bishop A5 on you know the H5 move is
still possible he can really play on
either side of the board he can play A5
A4 the key for Fabi is not just not to
spend too much time to trust his
intuition which he's been doing so well
and he does it again H5 great move seems
to me like Black's play is just out
weighing White's play in the center yeah
and also I've learned this from Fisher
random chess you nearly never want to
put your Knights on G3 and B3 they're
just terrible especially if they can't
Leap Forward and here neither of them
can ever Leap Forward and they're easy
targets for the opponent's pawns uh look
how these Knights will be forced to
retreat lose time and therefore white
will lose more influence on the center
these Knights want to be closer towards
the middle of the board and I think just
two misplaced pieces here for white
gives black the advantage nice move by
Fabi the H Pawn is coming it decided the
previous game between these two and it
might well decide this one if the white
knight is forced back Black's Knight
will be able to start getting active
yeah it feels like White's overextended
slightly nice visual looking position
for white but nothing to do next that's
always the problem in these positions
yeah I was looking at tactics I'm like
is E5 now the move because like I mean
his Buffy's is is pushing on you on your
head right now he's definitely trying to
get you right now 85 is a big move but
after E5 I was looking at takes takes
and then after Knight moves Knight H5
but you have Bishop F5 I think is it in
between he's just since look there and
you're looking kind of crazy after
Bishop F5 Maybe
um yeah or the other I was looking at
Knight D5 but maybe that probably works
too just Bishop it for a while the
engine doesn't move what is this
complicated stuff what is this screen G3
maybe and then Queen G3 okay but in
Bishop C2 oh you think oh my goodness
and then black takes on b366
so maybe it does work maybe it's time to
go for E5 here just complicate things it
is what it is I'm playing fobby we
learning this is a learning experience
because like it definitely if you don't
take the chances it it's just gonna be
rough for you too I mean you are playing
Five you need to win in fact uh draw
does not cut it so E5 probably is a move
here H4 is going to happen eventually so
you might as well play E5 now
yeah it might be your one chance if
you're forced to start retreating you
might never get another chance to attack
and that was my advice before the game
just take your chances just kind of
gamble at some point and
promise you are playing Fabi if
objectively his position is sound he'll
calculate his way through that big mess
that we just showed on the board and
he'll find a way out the other side for
black but
maybe it is now or never Jules weighing
up that moment two and a half minutes
spent on this one move he's kind of
burning his Bridges again it's like
earlier long think often means he's
calculating but
is it going to be good calculation
that's the big question
what else that's the other question here
right all right what else
down by almost three minutes on the on
the clock Jewels moving side big trouble
here and he has to find a way to win
this game it all comes down to those two
nights one on the queen side one on the
king side if a white knight could only
just magically transport itself on that
F3 Square things would look a lot
different for Jules musad's position but
it is a far away and Fabby showing
aggressive play with strong positional
Foundation today game one a strategic
Masterpiece and even this one with the
black pieces he's played Flawless chess
so far yeah two completely different
games in terms of what is on the board
but if you take the high level Arc of
the game it almost seems similar the way
the Fabi just imperceptively creeps up
on his opponent's position and before
you know it in the blink of an eye he's
like winning it's honestly Artistry by
Fabiano caruana but he's got a lot of
work to do in this game yeah the evil
bar keeps dropping but the center is
percolating one little mistake and you
give white a big initiative White's
pieces are nicely masked in the center
so Fabi has to be very very careful here
maybe push that pawn down to H4 the
Knight will have to take a visit to the
H1 Hotel what if I go E5 anyway after H4
I mean you might as well I don't even
care you know how we like this chest
Diamond then I might have to go to the
good night bar rather than calculating
that line rage four he's on the board he
plays Knight H1 oh that's always fun
when have you ever done that in the game
have you ever played Knight H1 yeah
yeah I played Knight H1 in a game and I
twisted it on the board I remember doing
it because you and I won the game too it
was cool because the night hopped back
over to G4 like it's so cool you never
put a knight in a corner like this so I
had to like twist it and then hit the
clock Fabiano okay
what's your night age fun story uh that
it didn't end well that's what I
remember don't try this at home kids
they're nice in the corner lights in the
room are dim but yeah lights in the
corner nobody puts we'll see in the
corner I don't know yeah exactly this
one shouldn't work for white but if
given two more moves the Knight might
re-centralize big if though Fabi this is
this moment to pounce when your opponent
steps back you normally want to go
forward so what can Fabi try
get all sorts of tricky ideas here yeah
Knight F2 Knight H5 comes to mind
actually that doesn't look half bad if
I'm honest Bishop C6 Knight F2 Knight H5
yeah and if you take on G7 I think the
Intermezzo Knight takes F4 might
be time to ring the death the death bell
for white he said do it first starts
with Knight H5 yeah okay wow okay but
now Bishop takes G7 is possible and from
a positional standpoint the trade of
dark squared Bishops should favor white
should give white a little bit of leeway
on the king side yeah at least now this
point is protected so that variation we
just showed works for white and there we
go the Bishops are off the board at
least this terrible piece that I was
talking about can spring forward to the
center a bit later I'm worried about
this one though it's just Frozen in the
corner on a terrible square if you ever
try to bring it in of course this Pawn
drops of course at this point uh this G3
Outpost as well is uh going to be
utilized by the Black Knight I just
don't see how this piece is ever getting
back in the game
if you're playing down the piece we all
know what's going to happen what the
result will be long term I'll be playing
down two pieces I mean the Nano H1 you
still forget to test there I mean then
you move it in the force hanging G3 is a
square two as well right looks all cool
oh my Knights on H1 and then you like I
have a knight on H one like oh snap
what do I do about that now Queen F6 is
going to be met with E5 and then Bishop
on D7 hangs so I think black maybe this
is still good after Pawn takes Pawn give
up the bishop and just take on F4 but
Fabi he doesn't want any of that he
wants to keep the status quo
and just drops back keeping control of
the game
looking good for black still just one
bad piece makes the whole position bad
quite often and that white knight we're
going to talk about it a lot the next
few minutes I have a feeling it's uh D3
if Fabi wants he can get the Queens off
now he can put his Queen on B6 that's
like safety scared approach uh with a
draw in mind but I'm sure he wants more
he knows that black probably has an
advantage here just because white
tonight is so bad on H1 there we go
talking about it already but uh okay
what else can black try
the bishop and prove the queen queen B6
looks fantastic honestly yeah played
well eval bar went all the way up on
that interesting such a logical move
practical
practical I think in match situation
terms great decision just uh getting the
Queens off the board there's no reason
for black to be worse in the ensuing
kind of queenless middle game he's doing
end game and it's going to be hard for
white to play again with that one bad
piece so get the Queens off the board
remove the risk two extra minutes on the
clock for Fabi if he doesn't win this
one he'll be kicking himself or if he
doesn't progress now to uh the next
round
he doesn't even need to win it he just
needs a draw Fabiano caruana and it
looks like he's doing everything right
very impressive play by him there up on
the clock Queen B6 get the Queens off
the board in our feature chat I saw it
was mentioned that Fabi is enjoying this
position it's a dream position with the
black pieces all your pieces your
Knights are the ones that are dominating
just compare it piece by piece the Rooks
on the open file for Fabi the Queens
have been traded off night on H5 better
than the night on H1 and Fabi going for
the break and the idea of this Pawn
sacrifice is that you get a very strong
hold on the central E5 Square it's
perhaps unnecessary but the position
just so good that you can even go for
this but actually you can't even take on
G5 tactically I think because after 95
Rook E3 black can snap off the bishop on
D3 and send the other night over to F4 I
love the Symmetry between fabi's night
on A5 which becomes strong and then the
Knight on H5 does the same exact thing
to deliver the death blow to the Rooks
yeah incredible yeah you could throw in
Rook C1 first so if you can't take G5
Jules tries to chase the C4 Knight away
a very ingenious idea and if the Knight
moves away then he's going to take on G5
Fab he might have missed that move but I
think he might be able to play even
Knight takes F4 Rook takes that 495
maybe you have to figure something out
here for black whoa Knight E5 double hit
maybe just G takes F4 honestly and send
that c Pawn down the board
on tech support and we'll do a quick
count black has a rook and two pawns for
whites two knights this one at least has
some life to breathe number two but uh
yeah it does feel like black spawns will
be strong enough I see this one joining
somehow late long term this Pawn is
going to be uh kind of running at some
point paralyzing the white Bishop Fabi
though at least here there's no control
and I think control has to go for this
he has gone for it with the this last
move of course but yeah slightly
surprising that fabi's even allowed any
complications at all he had full control
no need to calculate suddenly James
calculation it's forced oh yes I think
calculation of everything here but of
course the Fabi is going to do it he has
the time too as well nice little time is
just a few more seconds now if he keeps
thinking he will be under obviously but
he's about to make a move he just
reached for the mouse there and is he
gonna go for Knight F4 is he just gonna
move the Knight away Knight F4
definitely is moving there it is he goes
for it complications are there you can
trust Fabi to calculate and find the
right line now the force the move you're
gonna have to take well he's going to
take probably on C4
well it's almost the same position yeah
he takes on F4 just to ruin Black's King
Side Pawn structure okay we see all the
moves that we predicted black vacating
the C4 Square for his Rook might be time
to get that other night into the game I
don't think it's enough though I just
don't see Jules winning this position
do you see him uh holding it London
that's because it's gonna I can't see a
draw happening somehow it's so
unbalanced
yeah the knights Against The Rook which
one is better
black spawns are all blockaded for now
they're all isolated something to hope
for visual why can't you say uh why
can't you see a win here for whatever
happening Daniel because of that C3 Pawn
honestly I just feel like that pawn is
too strong and in a Time scramble these
positions are always easier for the side
with the passer I think fabby's gonna
play Bishop A4 next try to get a pair of
Bishops off the board and really
Bank on that c Pawn on the other hand
Jewel trying starting to hunt for those
King side pawns so you better succeed
with that c Pawn you can also go Rook E8
to B8 to B2 fabi's got to find the right
arrangement to maximize the value of
that c Pawn but I think he's going to
make it happen
following the commentator's advice
always a bad idea take take
wow and that moved B3 definitely took
value by surprise things are still under
control for black but obviously Fabi has
no idea of the objective evaluation on
the position we saw him there slow down
take a minute he has played the last few
moves for us until things are still fine
for black but it is a mess way messier
than what it was and that's exactly what
Jules musad wants now that Bishop A4 is
on the board it's not a move that our
silicon friend approves of but it's so
natural you want the path of that seat
Pawn to be cleared up what is wrong with
it is what I'm struggling to understand
yeah how's his shoes even survive the
next few weeks that's the big question
he's got a minute on his clock and again
he's taking so long just because it's
just so hard to put your finger on what
to do yeah Knight G4 Maybe
yeah just try and create some threats
and some folks in there
it's just a one move threat though
threatening a check threatening a fork
and blackbrook does want to move anyway
I think this is the idea anyway next
move so okay he's eliminated this I like
this uh now he's blockaded this black
pawn and I'm guessing black wants to
defend this Pawn I'm not sure which Rook
you use to defend it but maybe the king
now comes over the next few moves if you
can keep this blockade your Knights will
pick off these pawns later in the game
don't need to rush necessarily
maybe it's enough maybe he's holding on
he can't hold but he needs to win that's
the thing about it you win or you are
eliminated there is no other option here
control she has to win he has to create
the chances to win he does have the two
knights here it's going to take a
Herculean task here I mean you have to
get the pawn and even if let's say we
trade a pair of Rooks I mean are you
really going to win with the two knights
it's difficult it's very difficult to
win but it's too nice we even started
out with our Timmy have in the first one
actually Timmy have Magnus Magnus just
blundered the piece on a D3 after Rook
B6 it was like crazy I was working two
pieces versus the rook and like it's
very hard to do that especially you're
playing 5v2 as well and you're missing
some pawns it's very difficult also 50
seconds
those are not very good night what do
you want are the two Bishops there
instead of the night because it's so
difficult to make play with that and
Fabi that defends the C3 pawn and now
the question is can black make progress
simply by putting the other Rook on the
B file and start trying to put a trade
on B2 King F1 played and wow now if it's
Rook be it David how do you explain that
uh was the first one a mouse slip rookie
he's given white a free move the white
king is even closer to stopping that
black seaport but maybe he thinks that
the white king is actually going to be
caught in the crossfire
I just realized that oh actually it
wasn't working I was thinking oh maybe
Rook takes A2 yeah right yeah that was
93 right oh man that's so sick he wants
to uh yeah just bring his Rook down if
he can force a trade of Rooks White's
Knights will lose a lot of their
strength uh White's Rook actually
complements those two white Knights
really well okay ugly move there B1 and
Rook takes E4 comes with the check right
spawns turning to crumble but then King
D3 so Jules trying to find his way
around all of the debris in the center
yeah Ah that's a crazy line that is
crazy
so many tactics black on jump over to
that first rank pin that night White's
King can move forward and it's
complications the jewel in Black's
position is that pawn on C3 but it looks
like Jules musad will be the one who'll
be picking it up at the end of it I
approve thank you
for everyone on the board we're
following this line King E2 we'll take
C4 King D3 on the board 26 seconds oh
Joe's gonna eliminate the C pawn and
like David pointed out the Pawn's gonna
start falling like flies another thing
when you're in a Time scramble the last
thing you want is to deal with two
knights that are running amok and
threatening 600 different Forks yeah and
the clock situation it's just totally
random at this point I don't even know
which side I would take I don't know who
has the objective Advantage but once
that black C Pawn disappears I don't
think White's in any danger of losing
again the question is whether he can win
but uh yeah at least he's kind of
achieved step one he's out of trouble
and okay is that white king in any
trouble can you just take that black C
Pawn there we go it's a fork hitting the
two black Rooks a check gets out of the
way White's King has to move
step forward now surely forward for the
win
but two legal moves there we go there it
is he's going for it Jules but things
are out of control here both players are
down to seconds and the Knights are
suddenly active black spawns are super
weak in the position is this a game now
for three results these nights I would
consider Rook before check trying to
force the King on to d58 oh it's
absolutely a game for three result so as
usual I've jinxed Fabi Who's down at
eight seconds now imperceptibly he makes
me it's a Time scramble Knight 65. you
might want to give one of the Rooks away
for the F3 Knight this idea occurred to
me no he's gonna give a check on D1 but
he's just giving away another important
white is just gobbling them all up and
oh he's panicking he's just dropping all
of his pawns and he's not creating any
threats of his own Rook A5 though is
easy to miss I would take the F Pawn
First just Knight F4 but don't play
Knight takes H4 he made that movement on
four seconds
wow and the bar drops off to the most
natural move now Jules oh he's got a
move he made that one with two seconds
left fabby's gonna pursue that Rook
until he forces the trade one second
oh okay the trade is inevitable at this
point let's go for checkmate whoa look
at the king tuck and roll later
why King's hiding the white Knights are
so far offside they need to recentralize
and now it's coming to F5 after that
last move the Jeep on Bush he is going
for blacks King right now Jules musad
will in nine seconds can he do this
it's a race white is actually going for
checkmate maybe with those two knights
and the white Rook
coming off the block that one by Fabby
he just cooperated with Jules now
neither five cups
rookie two no you can't play it 96.
he wins 96 King D7 plus a four three
Rook D6 I like it cutting the black king
off No Escape now the other white knight
is going to come in with some checks
he's coming in some people made on F6
drop the king back White's King is super
safe
oh my goodness unbelievable these nights
look at him stand up with a hard Flex
there wow
what a comeback there by the French
Grand Master Fabiano caruana had
everything under control but some
inaccuracies in that time scramble and
Jules musad made the most of that
opportunity how impressive was that
incredibly impressive of course I jinxed
Fabby as usual but he had it under
control until the very end he could have
forced The Rook trade instead got a
little bit over ambitious and you just
see the power of the knights in time
scrambles Tanya and we see Fabi there
he's exasperated and you can understand
why
couldn't believe what he let slip out
and now this match goes into an
Armageddon and in an Armageddon anything
can happen we are waiting for the time
bits by the players David what was that
big moment in this one I think it's uh
as Daniel said black missed the
opportunity to get rid of the Rooks with
no Rooks on the board the knights would
struggle to coordinate they'd struggle
to post problems on their own and it was
uh in this position after the white Rook
tried to run away that I think Fabi
could have nailed it down he could have
locked in the win just by not giving the
check by actually chasing the white Rook
the white Rook has nowhere to hide if it
steps back you chase it if uh actually
you lose a knight as well but the white
Rook cannot escape the trade and this
would have ended in a draw most likely
instead if we fast forward it ended in
disaster for Fabi instead look how the
white Knights have suddenly combined
with their Rook nothing to do for black
if you push a pawn for example this game
would end in Checkmate beautiful pattern
here the knights cage the King The Rook
checkmates instead he had to walk into a
fork and it was disastrous anyway a
nasty check from the Knight and white
one material winning the game
that was a big takeaway for all the
chess kids out there just how much
resilience can pay off and Juice Musa
does exactly that which means that with
that win take a look at the score line
because we have been talking about this
ladies and gentlemen we've got an
Armageddon on our hands the chest action
continues uh
just a kid
cup and we've got something very special
to show you but for our non-subscribers
we will go into a twitch break
subscribers stay right here
[Music]
we've been having so much fun today the
first game Fabi takes it the second game
shoots takes it and more fun coming up
with the Armageddon but it's not just us
because the chief chess officer of Chess
kid my client also had a lot of fun with
chess kid in Peru
[Applause]
[Music]
this is feeding Master Mike Klein we're
having our own chess kid Cup in Lima
Peru I don't speak Spanish but I speak
the international language which is
chess take a look
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
they love my
life
[Music]
oh my God that was a lot of fun to watch
but also here in the studio James Canty
having some fun lots of good moves the
sauces I mean I just I feel it every
time I hear that music you know shout
out to y'all at home okay get your dance
on right stand up exercise a little bit
feels good get your dance on get your
moves on and it is also of course it's
all about the chest fund that we are
having and once again my client uh took
on uh
with some tactics take a look impressive
stuff
okay this is white to move and when way
to the win win
aha I found it okay so you probably
night okay and you have to bring this
Knight to H5
it's it's sweet geometry but check so
the king
um I I think I solved it so yeah I
believe the king is here yeah the king
is here it moves here yep exactly now
you go Knight E7 only move I believe
okay you can go C6 you can't go back so
the Knight D5 okay everything goes to E6
you're just you four can win normally
yeah normally
wow okay wait a second
serving E6 I like that you're getting
like five epiphanies
G7 okay
here and now you go 98.
okay but finish off the puzzle 98 yeah
if the King goes here to G6 you go
Knight E7 so the King goes C6 and now
you go Knight C7 and you you take
normally exactly
[Music]
how cool was that David the chess kids
today they are so strong they're so
strong I hate playing kids these days
because they always seem to beat me and
uh really great solving that from Tani
and uh nice to see those kids in Peru as
well just uh loving chess
it is a lot of fun and of course so
never so much fun to play against these
kids and we had to put David on a spot
because he took on a bunch of school
kids
it's gonna be a challenge I hope for the
best I think you'll be really hard what
we're going to do today I'm going to
play against 12 of you at the same time
so there's two ways to beat me either
you can Checkmate me or you can win on
the clock
it's
like impossible
ready I'll start with you guys okay
[Music]
this is awesome
I hope he doesn't I found the first
trickster here okay
[Music]
okay
well two minutes here I didn't realize
I'll where's the Checkmate I don't see
it
I was quite ready by trying to get the
points and then I ended up losing
[Music]
sorry thank you so much for the game
well played thanks for the games
yeah teamwork I like it I think it was
kept me no matter what happened there we
go thank you so much
that was hard work well done everyone
you made me sweat
so much fun watching David Holland run
around sweating it out that wasn't easy
doing that wasn't easy
more calories uh playing them than I
have in the last year combined it was a
workout they made me work and uh some
future chess stars there
wow what impressed you the most about
the kids what was that biggest Trend oh
just the way they worked together they
were kind of teaming up kind of as soon
as I turned my back one of them would
make a move so my clock would run down
and they really kind of embraced The
Challenge and yeah they're gonna go far
in life no matter what they do just
great kids and uh clearly the parents
out there as well shout out to them
supporting their kids chess Journeys is
such a brilliant tool to ensure that you
have the ideal educational and social
outcomes we see there so many chess kids
around the world it's becoming a part of
school curriculums social fun you learn
to also respect your opponent Daniel and
uh not just think about your ideas but
what your opponent wants to play and
that's a great life lesson it most
certainly is there's a tendency to just
think that chess makes you better at
math and that's all that matters but it
does give you a lot of social skills
teaches you how to act with respect when
you win and also when you lose
and now we see just kids having fun
playing chess uh across the world green
and yellow pieces Simon what do you
think about that
it's my honest answer to that you know I
don't like the green pieces I just get
too confused
all right Simon doesn't approve of the
color combination but the kids we've
seen them with some incredible tactics
combination that they do solve and uh
James uh Simon there with us uh Simon
kids super strong when it comes to those
at least the puzzles on the board yeah
definitely it's the best way to learn
doing puzzles so always get your puzzles
done as everyone in the middle there has
been saying
um so yeah we're gonna do an update now
because there's on division two and
three because there's been loads of
stuff going on there obviously uh we've
got Armageddon now in the top division
which is going to be fascinating but
let's start with the winners final and
this is quite close but I guess as
expected the favorite fetisev has taken
a bit of a lead there and let's remember
the winner of this is only one more
mini-match away and they will play one
of these guys of going through to
division one Dimitri age rating has won
that first match and mamajarov has won
the other match so now adri aching is
playing against mamagara for mamajara's
got the lead there that could be an
eye-watering final to decide division
two mamajarov versus fedexv so very
exciting there
and we can also have a quick look at the
vision free we saw that gatakowski got
knocked out by this young player lazovic
and David Navara has also lost against
the Vitali so very good result and there
is the final the losers final should I
say to decide who is going to play
against Harry Krishna and then against
uh
um remind me Pitch show in the final for
the uh championships of division three
so there's a lot going on we're getting
there in those divisions and uh there
will only be one very soon it's a very
exciting stuff
wow that sounds like a lot of Grudge
matches could be coming out with
taking on chakra of the action continues
but right now it is about the bids how
important is it in this one to get the
black pieces for the color James it's
very important I mean Jules right now is
feeling like yeah I just took out Fabi
like if I get black here this could be
it and this should be huge for jewels
and fabi's like I gotta bounce back I
know I was winning there I messed it up
if I get black here we gotta we gotta
win it that's it James what's your
prediction who's gonna win the bid who
will make the lower bed you know what
the Baseline got to be here how low can
you go Daniel well we've seen players I
mean we've seen players go as low as
like six or seven minutes I would not
advise that my guess is that the players
will hover around 9 to 11 minutes I
actually think Fabi might have a higher
bid let me predict 11 minutes for Fabi
and 9 30 for jewels
yeah yeah very
very pleased come in and it is ready
let's reveal
wow Fabiano caruana wins the bid with
just 30 second Martin nine minutes 58
seconds was the bid by Fabi he picks the
black color and Jules moose out with 10
minutes 27 seconds loses the bid we'll
start with the white pieces with 15
minutes on the clock Zeus has to win an
assignment before we let you go I'm
gonna ask you that just losing it out by
30 seconds nine and a half minutes to
Fabiano caruana he gets result odds how
difficult is this for Jules
one of the best players in the world but
he has proven in that last game that he
keeps his calls so well and they are
offered a move so I'm going to go back
to you very quickly but I'm actually
going to go for Jewels I like the
underdog come on Jules
nice shirt by the way Simon yeah this is
what's gonna happen to Fabi he's gonna
just resign
wow and it's the Spanish but this time
the exchange variation so uh White has
parted with the bishop for a black
knight but has broken the black
structure in the meantime black has a
pair of double pawns on the C file
has the bishop pair though to compensate
and very quick moves up to this point
clearly jewel is trying to put pressure
on the clock but he has walked into a
very well prepared Fabiana caruana and
queens are off the board as well
objectively black is totally fine here I
feel and uh it's up to Joel now to work
some magic to imbalance this one or
maybe to win on the clock long term
what are our conclusions we're already
in a queenless position
I'm not gonna lie probably again maybe
opening choice to like keep pieces on
and complicate things if you make it
easy for father you mean
um yes I have lower time but this is
easy I just improve my position right
The Exchange variation is something
Bobby liked to play sometimes Bobby
Fischer that is they like to play it I
mean but this is a it's different in
time exchange right now playing for
Armageddon here too is playing for a win
Queens already off the board I think
it's gonna be quite difficult of a task
for Jules
yeah Daniel who do you prefer here white
or black yeah I think Fabi came
incredibly well prepared with that rare
Queen F6 line which essentially forced a
lot of pieces off the board right off
the bat I actually don't know that Jules
prepared for that I think he was just
disappointed to find that Fabi knew all
of the best moves I know that's a first
for Abby to be well prepared in the Roy
Lopez mind-boggling right but this is
such an easy well-defined position for
black the Bishop from E6 can drop back
to F7 reinforce the H Pawn you could
bring the Rook into E8 how is Jules
going to stir up complications because
yeah you've got four extra minutes on
the clock but 9 30 is an eternity to
play an end game that's this simple
yeah and jewels definitely shouldn't
have been surprised by this variation I
do recall Fabiano playing this rare
Queen F6 move on several occasions
including a very nice win against York
Meyer in uh Dortmund a few years ago so
he's got form here Fabi he's got great
experiences he's got a solid position
everything looks like it's in his favor
and we talked about that in the previous
game again things looked like they were
under control for him but they did
spiral a bit later on look at that black
knight they're beautiful in the center
of the board you can never kick it away
that Black Knight without pushing a pawn
and weakening some squares in the
process I think fabi's done everything
right so far and uh just curious fact
before this game Jules had won four
whites in a row dang coming into this
one he'd beaten Fabi he'd won uh
yesterday a couple of times with whities
really really powerful with the white
pieces but it's always been with Queens
on the board always complicated
it feels like it's not necessarily his
style which was to go into this type of
end game
so okay Fabio preserving the bishop pair
two Bishops for black could play a role
long time but the knights are jumping
you could play rookie eight and then
meet Knight F5 with Bishop f8 so Knight
F5 in itself is not as scary of a move
as it may appear important not to
overreact here if Fabby is afraid of it
he could position his Bishop back on E6
but I like the placement of the bishop
on F7 just because it is freeing up that
Rook uh in terms of guarding the H5 Pawn
so important moment here for Fabi to
find the right piece arrangement
yeah really nice move there uh just
dropping the black Bishop back and
because Bishops are long between long
range pieces even on their start squares
like this bishop would be and I think we
might be headed in this direction even
here the Bishops are extremely powerful
and uh black might have this fractured
structure that we talked about the four
versus three not making a great
impression on the queen side because
these pawns are doubled but at the right
moment Fabby will have the option
potentially of pushing this Pawn forward
and trading off creating an outside
majority on the queen side for white
it's very difficult to push very
difficult to improve his pieces first
Jules does that by trying to double up
his Rooks stack up those Rooks on the D
file he's making progress maybe I've
been too harsh on White's position here
I just have a lot of experience from the
black side and ah I don't know if
there's too much to worry about uh for
Fabi but uh yeah the clock will be a big
factor still a lot of tension left in
the in the position
okay Fabi for the first time really
thinking in this game
yeah you got a lot of moves a lot of
options and so it does depend really
what he wants here I mean it's all about
improving which means moving pawns
pieces to better squares than they were
before sometimes even prepping or
stopping potential things from happening
like Daniel down you mentioned Knight of
five Bishop f8 right so even on Bishop
eight maybe even one time you got B6 you
have C6 is a little committal there you
might even think about a pawn to C4 it
does open up the line though but C6 yes
that's understandable so many options
here for for black
so many options you mentioned it's
committal because you weaken some dark
squares but Black's King is ready to
kind of Step into the square that that
pawn is just vacated and cover
everything
looks like a slightly risky move but
well Justified for Fabi and now that
white knight the pride and joy in the
center of the bud kicked back forced
back and uh maybe you gained some time
by going to F4 retreating in that
direction just because black has a
weakness on the H file but
you know I don't know where to go from
there yeah presumably Fabi would meet
Knight F4 with G6 that also restricts
the G3 Knight by protecting the F5
square and then you can consider
dropping his dark grid Bishop back to E7
or f8 and if all of the Rooks come off
the board I really really don't see how
white generates any winning chances
again that Knight on E5 really
stabilizing Black's hole position it's
virtually unassailable maybe Knight F4
and then the Knight can drop back to D3
but Black's Bishops are more than
capable of holding the fort James
mentioned C5 C4 could come at some point
to rectify Black's Pawn structure as
well so I think Fabia quitting himself
very well in the end game thus far can
Jules find a way to complicate this game
in pose more serious long-term problems
yeah everything we see so far tends to
kind of hint that black is just totally
fine yeah if you get all the Rooks off
the board we tend to say that Bishops
gain power the more pieces leave the
board especially when they're in a pair
and I think blacks Bishops actually give
great long-term winning chances let
alone drawing chances which suit Fabby
yeah Jewels need something now but what
is that you have to retreat your knight
it's not what you want
you can jump in and give a check but
black just moves the king yeah nothing
gained maybe he's looking at Knight B6
to A4
um especially if you have King C7 there
uh but then he plays B6 yeah my idea was
obviously a C4 Bishop B6 but he just
plays B6 himself maybe we double and we
might have Knight B6 there there's some
chances maybe like Knight B6 King C7
Knight A4 and just attack you be a
little bit annoying it really depends on
where you put your king to as well it's
logical to go King C7 and after King C7
we have Knight A4 and then after a B6
now we double the Rooks with a threat of
Knight B6 on the board if you move the
bishop we trade the Rooks uh but he has
to go but should be seven but then that
last Knight F5 so you see how I'm just
hitting you every move I have hits every
move so I can create some counter play
here maybe pressure you on the clock and
really you know try to bank on five
making a mistake which is very rare when
he has time of course he has time he's
gonna think now if he doesn't have time
then you know it uh mistakes like we saw
in the last game are definitely uh
evident can happen so I do like this
Knight B6 idea it's quite interesting
yeah I thought it was a dead end but I
think you're completely right there
James you have to try something like
that at least you're forcing your
opponent to think forcing them to react
and calculate uh Knight B6 to A4 at
least black those double pawns might
come back to haunting
I think you need to move now though the
five minute Advantage he started with is
rules they're pretty much gone one and a
half minutes in it now and Counting
fabi's played super quick up to this
point only invested two minutes she also
spent six minutes to get here
he needs to speed up if you have no time
Advantage this position is not easy to
play with white especially if you need
to win
just give the check just move first
think later that's right that's right
sank for estate later Knight F6 psych
don't try that at home Knight F6 does
not work
now just over a minute on the clock for
Jules musad he has to win this game on
demand a draw would mean that Fabi takes
the match he does give a check and after
the king king Advance he will fall back
with that Knight to A4 putting pressure
on C5 how difficult is it for Fabi
psychologically right now even though
the position is under control all right
that's a nice tactic hitting that Bishop
on D6 you take my knight on B6 I'll take
your Bishop on D6 but before we Deep
dive into this position David is it a
bit of a challenge to forget the fact
that Fabi could have wrapped up the
match in the last game it always is but
when the clock is ticking it's kind of
nice that it's Armageddon because you
don't have time to get emotional you
don't have time to kind of reflect on
the past you only have seven minutes
you've got to play instantly no added
time after every move so actually Fabi
maybe it helps that it's Armageddon
rather than just a normal regular rapid
game meanwhile one set of Rooks off the
board and yeah that tactic that one move
trick that he played Rook fd1 I don't
like it at all it's just helped black
get a pair of Rooks off the board that's
what Harry wanted anyway it was super
flashy but fabby's not gonna fall for
these one move tricks and Jules can't do
anything drastic here to complicate the
position if he plays B4 then that just
sends him into the gutter after Knight
to C4 so I really I just don't see how
he's gonna pose any problems he's not
even up on time barely up on time
anymore this is just not looking good
maybe get the knight from A4 over to the
king side Knight c392 Knight F4 but even
if you do all that all black needs to do
is play G6 and the H5 Pawn is fully
protected this will take a minor miracle
yeah
struggling for ideas clearly here Jules
clock is balanced time is leveled out
he's uh really lacking inspiration and
it's just not the type of position at
least if they're Queens on the board
stay true to his style of jewels and uh
yeah keep Queens on the board at least
you can generate something play for
tricks later on
here I see nothing just say to yourself
as Davis says David for 2024. stay true
to yourself Chad it's what he was saying
that's correct I mean hey we have some
moves here though a few moves 92 trying
to reroute the Knight I mean this you
might as well offer a draw like you know
of course uh that loses the match for
you but uh at the end of the day this is
definitely a difficult one how are you
going to create the chances I'll tell
you hi James it's an Armageddon you just
keep as many pieces as you can on the
board and try to flag your opponent is
that going to be the strategy here for
Jews to try and play fast but he's the
one who's down by 30 seconds on the
clock it might be Fabi who might end up
flagging shoes 7 27 and that's still
just in eternity that gives you so much
time to react to
unexpected moves so it takes away you
know the the classic flagging technique
of throwing unexpected problems at your
opponent Jewels just kind of maneuvering
maneuvering trying to poke in Pride but
oh okay Rook takes the 80 wants to
recapture with the bishop very important
to keep the B6 Pawn protected and with
every piece that disappears White's
winning chances already slim continue to
diminish even further
Yeah you mentioned over seven minutes
you probably played 10 bullet games
plenty of time Ocean of Time and okay
he's trying to get rid of black strong
Knight in the center makes a lot of
sense strategically to trade or not to
trade does black allow this do you
acquiesce to this uh trade of knights
right now or do you step back
it keeps attention what you think
it's a really good question that what
are the pieces you want to keep on and
which ones you want off because look at
again it's all about the pawn structures
you've white it's got four pawns on the
king side uh black with four pawns on
the queen side but hard to imagine Fabi
ever getting a past Pawn on the queen
side if this is a pure King Pawn ending
James I think Jules will have real
chances here because it's just easier
for him to get a past Pawn on the king
side it can create one definitely you
can create one but we do have the
Bishops right and those Bishops in open
positions sometimes it even says the two
Bishops can compensate for being down
upon in an end game in fact you've even
seen many in-games for like I'm up a
pawn but I still lose the game or a draw
when your opponent has the two Bishops
it's very important to have that like
Bobby has he's not even down anything so
yeah okay we can create a pass Pawn
maybe but I do have the Bishops and of
course I'm going to be able to control
both color complexes having the Bishops
in this opening game or when it opens up
at least so do we all agree that Fabi
needs to keep the bishop there don't
trade off all the minor pieces
don't trade divisions but you can't
trade the pawns I think that's probably
not an issue maybe Jules wants to drive
oh whoa G5 trading even more pawns a
little Pond Cube there that's a
committal move but it might work out if
you can force all those King side pawns
off the board you'll have to be careful
because in the ensuing position the
g-pawn is going to be isolated so the
bishop on d8 uh is tasked with defending
both of Black's weaknesses and yet it's
doing so very successfully yeah just to
show that Daniel you're talking about a
position such as this one where Black's
Bishop is pretty much stuck it's
immobilized defending this Pawn
defending this Pawn but
why Why move it yeah yeah it's perfectly
fine 24-hour parking
24-hour Park yeah white has no way of uh
creating anything here stirring anything
up so it feels like fabi's found a
really nice antidote to this perceived
action on the king side and yeah if you
prevent your opponent creating any past
points you will prevent your opponent
winning the game
so G5 nice move from Fabi five minutes
against six
I'll mention as well the Spanish
exchange it's the only opening I played
until I was about 13 years old so
between the ages of 5 and 13 and if you
trade off one of Black's Bishops for
example if you imagine the two dot
Square Bishops disappearing from the
board if it's Knight versus Bishop white
has fantastic winning chances if you can
create a passport but uh yeah as you
guys mentioned pipe dream right now
no way to do that
well under five minutes visuals
they keep the tension because it's moved
G5 all through the match but I've always
been having this direct approach in all
positions we see a decision has been
made made the G5 bonds are off the board
the G4 Pawn will be off the board as
well King G3 now if you capture the king
steps up and that might not be ideal for
black to allow the counter to play with
white skin yeah very shrewd move there
by by Joseph a lot of newer players
would automatically play H4 check
because it's exciting to get a protected
passer that would actually be bad
because white could undermine that pawn
chain with a later F4 Fabby steers clear
of that he's just gonna go back and
forth between C7 and d8 he's not going
to do anything unless he's absolutely
forced to as David shows this is exactly
the way to create your own problems yeah
he just uh maintains the status quo the
status quo
he just defends this pawn and he's
saying okay you go you cannot go further
you cannot pass here the white king if
it ever wants to step forward will get
blocked off by this bishop instead he re
I gotta say re-root reroute
are you a lorry driver
and the Knight wants to Spring Forward
interesting Jules is finding chances
though he's creating something at least
asking questions or Fabby strategically
for casuals and that's what the
Armageddon is about right you've got to
try to get your opponent to just think
burn time on the clock uh has to find a
way to do that quick because he's down
on the clock I like how there's tension
on the king's side because that means
the game is still alive this idea of
King G3 King H3 trying to provoke Fabi
to push that H Pawn
it's a real try yeah Jules is honestly a
wizard at creating chances where there
seemed to be none
this is suspiciously following The
Narrative of the previous game except
the position looks even more lifeless at
least the last game was a middle game
and then an unbalanced end game this one
is a little bit unbalanced in terms of
the pawn structure but fabby's default
is to do nothing he just has to find a
good spot for his King which he did now
the knight from B2 cannot access E5
Jules has to figure out where he's going
to deploy this Knight maybe to C4 and D2
and F1 again he can't milk Black's clock
down he's down a full minute on the
clock and we saw Jews just shake his
head a moment ago he's running out of
ideas already and in terms of ease of
play whose position uh kind of is easier
to play whose ideas are easier to
understand it's certainly black you just
do nothing and that one as fabi's doing
that just yo-yoing back and forth with
his Bishop he's doing it within seconds
for Jules he has to create something to
get the creative juices flowing you need
time he doesn't have that I think he's
running out of steam already
I think our Jewels can try and do is get
that night from one edge of the board to
the other edge of the board a knight D1
Knight F2 Knight H3 is an idea you see
that G5 pawn it could be a potential
Target is that Knight headed over to H3
James absolutely I mean you're gonna
move that Knight around the only thing
we do have is the night that's the
imbalance we have so you want to use the
imbalance that you can okay you have two
Bishops though lsq you got both color
complexes great job well I got this
little tricky knife that could bounce
around and in fact in the last game the
Knight was the culprit in fact that I
have helped him win the game yeah so
looking good with this this Knight
maneuver so far and you also have the
pass Pawn in the center
yeah but now Fabi for the first time in
this game is trying to create counter
Play Active play he's pushing his
majority he does have four pawns on the
queen side he's trying to get rid of his
doubled C pawns he's gonna just push at
some point in the near future try to
create a pass point of his own it comes
with uh okay he's pushing the a pawn
instead there are targets white spawns
are on light squares black has a light
squared Bishop it comes with some risk
if you push the wrong Pawn but he's
going for it who's playing for a win now
well he's just trying to get all the
pawns off the board if Jules takes and
then plays A3 then black will strike
with C4 that Bishop on E7 will make its
presence fell I love the way the Fabi is
handling this he's not just passively
waiting around he's saying listen if you
shake The Hornet's Nest enough I'm going
to be the one to take this draw that
straight on B3 helps only black because
now white has a serious Target the king
is now stuck on C3 and White's already
slim chances continue to diminish closer
and closer to zero yeah if you can't
play with an active King you will not
play for a win and right now those
Bishops look at them we pointed them
down in One Direction they're also
staring off the other direction the
White Knight is also totally there's no
idea there's just literally no moves
here you can just Shuffle and that's it
yeah oh man I would be playing for a win
here with black and I think fabi's doing
the same he wants to bring his Bishop
into the center
first those Bishops off the board you
cannot physically lose this what's the
trade we said Bishop
that's disrespectful from the bar just
like completely like yeah you this is
over hit the button it says the bar but
he doesn't find it James Goes Bishop E7
yeah he doesn't need to find it he knows
he's happy with the draw it's not like
getting off the rule
bonjour's nothing to do apart from
repeat here again Bishop D4 now we'll
find it oh okay also good because now
he's fixed another week because now the
Knight is stuck guarding G4 the king is
still guarding B3 and fabby's King can
walk around and mop up all of white
spawns easy pickings this is resignable
for white look at the lean back
now because there's nothing to do
and that's it wow Fabiano caruana takes
too much
in the Armageddon but it's still he
hasn't he hasn't repeated it for the
third time
wow
do we still have a game on but playing
for the loss yeah King T4
even if fatty bone is a fork it's
probably still going to be a draw oh
wow Bond down you've got to try to a way
to win this position I can't even find a
self-mate for black hair hard to imagine
the night being able to do anything and
that's the second Pawn that falls
yeah just trade off that final white
pawn and nothing left to play for and
the players have actually just agreed to
agree wow
pieces after a drop flawlessly played
Armageddon there was a Miss in a game
two by the American Grandmaster but in
the whole match he has been dominating
and he will be the one who will play
Jordan van Forest next for the spot in
the Grand Final Jews moves out there the
last minute replacement here at the
chess get cup congratulations to him for
the great chess that he showed here but
that was just a Fabby day out tonight
yeah three Exquisite games and yes Fabby
lost the second one he panicked in time
pressure that's really been the only
weakness that Fabi has shown but really
steering the Armageddon in his direction
from move one great preparation so
unbreakable with the black pieces well
played in the Armageddon and well done
to jewels I mean great run but you just
met at the hands of an on-form Fabian we
know how that usually goes
really badly would be the answer to that
but it was a fight on the fight indeed
does continue big moments in this one
David what was the standout point for
Fabi here for me it was towards the end
Fabi really instructively showing us
what you should aim for when you have
Bishops versus Knights and it was uh
this position a draw is pretty much
guaranteed at this point but he actually
went for the win by pushing his Pawn to
B4 locking down White's pawns all on
light squares the white king forced to
retreat and note how this bishop
dominates everything he keeps the White
Knight honest protecting the spawn it
keeps the white king honest protecting
this pawn and it was clear that the
black king could simply March in if Fabi
needed to win he would likely have found
the fact that Bishop takes porn Knight
takes Pawn he could simply have trapped
the White Knight the black pieces are so
dominant this white knight will run out
of squares shortly and uh instead Fabby
took it to a draw but he progressed to
the next round anyway
spectacular chess start from finish
today so far by Fabiano caruana can he
keep up the momentum through the day
because he needs to do that the
challenges are not over as he will be
facing Jordan van forest in that final
spot race to the Grand Final and here we
see how the day went Savi took the first
game the second game he was dominating
the match could have ended but Jules
Musa with some great resilience strikes
back and then it went down to the
Armageddon with the black pieces Fabiano
Carona kept it completely under control
was the one who was pushing for the win
and in the end we saw a repetition
that's how this one ended more chess kid
action coming up after the switch break
[Music]
do you love following chess.com events
and want to join the team
are you a passionate chess fan with
experience in organizing events and
tournaments you might be exactly who
we're looking for to come on board as an
eventual coordinator use command apply
in chat or go to go.chess.com events
underscore coordinator underscore apply
to submit your application now
foreign
Academy we've taught chess to a hundred
thousand kids with Summer around the
corner we're gearing up for camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
um the Magnus chess Academy welcome Adam
hi Tanya thanks it's great to be here
[Music]
nice to have you here with us at the
chess kid cup and Adam the Magnus chess
Academy has taught over a hundred
thousand kids that is awesome work tell
our audience some of the key features of
learning chess at the Academy
yeah I'd be happy to so it happens in a
few ways there's an in-person component
and also an online Academy program which
is probably the most relevant for the
Champions chess tour audience because it
can be accessed anywhere in the world
um and the way that works is that it's
for kids ages 5 to 14
and they take semi-private or small
group chess lessons uh no more than
eight kids at a time with a coach
and they take lessons once a week and
progress through a variety of different
topics and curricula
um and they learn a lot the lessons are
very interactive and they also get to
make friends with other kids in their
class that are around the same age and
the same skill level
because the social part is so important
for kids to have fun
same thing that these are semi-private
lessons because for online classes one
of the big challenges is always that a
lack of one-on-one interaction so how do
you overcome that at the Academy
no I mean that that's a great point and
I think that is one of the things that
makes Magnus Academy different
um you know when you're watching a video
on YouTube uh not that there's anything
wrong with that these are great
especially uh the CCT broadcasts of
course uh but when you're watching that
you're not interacting typically with uh
the the presenter
um when the the size of the class is
limited to no more than eight kids
there's a lot of uh interaction so the
coach knows who the kids are helps track
their progress the kids know the coach
they know each other they often become
friends and you know may meet up in real
life at in-person tournaments uh and I
think that social component is very
important for kids
um
uh adults too actually like I was
personally in my own uh chess career I
was plateaued at about a rating of 2000
or 2100 uh for a number of years until I
made friends with a couple people who
were about the same level and we just
practiced all the time uh kind of
inspired each other to get better and
that was how I eventually hit 2200 uh
was just through playing with some
friends so I think you know this is an
opportunity to offer the same thing to
kids uh who may be in an area where they
don't know other kids who like chess or
who are at their same skill level
that's so cool so they got to find a
similar sort of a community and improve
together and you were talking about
inspiration so I think the big question
on everyone's mind is uh it's the Magnus
just Academy do the kids actually get to
meet and maybe play with Magnus
uh yeah they do so sometimes he'll he'll
drop by and um they'll do a q a with the
kids and answer some questions
um or sometimes they'll challenge him uh
you know he'll play a bunch of them in a
simul nobody's beating them yet which is
not too surprising I guess uh but I
think the the question and answer uh
that he's done are really great because
um I think what the many of the kids
have had questions about is just things
like
um you know we had a question uh from a
little girl asking him if he'd ever
cried when he lost a game uh and he gave
a great answer and you know I think he
basically said like yeah it's natural to
get upset when you lose and get a little
bit emotional but you know you cry a
little bit and then you kind of pick
yourself back up and you know go try
hard in your next game uh and I think
you know answers like that are very
inspirational to a young person that's
just starting out in their chess career
yeah that's super cool because it's not
just learning uh through his gains we're
also you know just being able to ask him
these questions and just looking at him
for the kids can be so inspiring that I
want to be Magnus Carlsen a one day
sounds really cool Adam tell us where
can everyone sign up and do you guys
have trial classes as well
yeah we do so um for any kids who are
interested in joining the academy
program and making some new friends and
improving at chess uh you can go to
chessacademy.com
trial there's a five dollar trial class
where you get the experience of this uh
semi-private lesson for an hour and you
just see if you like it
um and if you're interested in more
in-depth programs over the summer when a
lot of kids are not in school you can
also go to chessacademy.com camp
Sandra if on Adam thank you so much I'm
sure a lot of our audience is inspired
to check out the Magnus chess Academy
and it was great to hear from you
great thank you for having me
so yeah Adam which bought from the
Magnus dress Academy definitely check
them out and you might get a chance to
meet and play against Magnus as well
while improving your chest and we are
seeing some Grandmaster level chess all
around in the Champions Chester not just
in division one but the big names in
division two and three as well Simon's
back in the studio Simon what's the big
update yeah hi well we're gonna have a
look at a very nice tactic from division
two let's remember whoever wins division
two goes up to division one so it's a
massive prize and we had two legends of
the game we had an old Legend I should
say mama jarov playing with the white
pieces here and he's playing the young
Indian tattoo sleeved character sad wani
and they had this position on the board
now you might be able to try to work
this out at home you've got the white
pieces black is suddenly pushing a pawn
towards your king so he's ready to open
up your well King on the left hand side
so you've got to be quick but what is
the most important detail with this
position it is that open Harry file and
we all love a bit of open Harry file so
what is the winning move well the
winning move is Bishop into the middle
into E5 and this is a really nice move
it threatens Rook up to the top giving
Checkmate so black has to really take
the bishop here and in the end black
decided to take the Knight and what's
White's idea well now that Bishop is out
of the way it's a clearance tactic the
White Queen can swing over to the action
and here it comes and now
yeah just resign my friend just reside
and that's what he did he resigned and
that made Mama jarov go through to the
next round where he's currently fighting
to try and get that place to division
one
Simon that was some incredible tactics
there that we're seeing and it just
becomes so complicated to face these
when you're playing on second on the
clock the fight in division two and
three chapter news but also in division
one in the losers final that's a big
match coming up where Fabiano caruana
faces the Dutch number two Jordan van
forest for a spot in the Grand Final it
will be a best of two with 15 minutes
for each of the playoffs and a three
second increment and once again if it's
a tie we might have another Armageddon
and siren before we let you go what are
your predictions for the match coming up
I think it's going to be very very
exciting I I don't know
um I'm gonna have to go for Fabiano I
think because uh he's warmed up now and
uh well you've seen how well my
predictions have gone so far so I mean
it's really hard to say does it help
that he's played a couple of games or is
it going to make him tired that's what
I'm thinking I think it's going to help
him I think it's good that he's warmed
up and ready for the action so Fabiano
all the way now he's ready for the
action we are ready for the action the
players are ready for the action let's
take a look and there they are Jordan
van Forest who's probably been sitting
back and enjoying the last match and
just taking in all the chess action
starts with the white pieces do you
think it favors Jordan the fact that
he's rested or Savvy being in a float
that's a bigger Advantage oh yeah I
think probably being in the flow is a
very scary fobby that's a very scary
fight but also you ordered I mean he was
able to take out you know Nakamura so
it's a big win for him he made it this
far only losing to Abdus so hey yes his
chances himself as well now
yes seems to be the theme of the day the
Spanish opening and uh Fabi he's shown
his expertise once
Jordan pausing now did he not watch the
shows yeah an hour ago have you playing
a main line relovers wow
yeah surely he should have predicted
this uh in a previous game jul musad
played the pawn in front of the White
Queen up one square to D3 against Fabi
Jordan what is he doing he's just
meditating and just throwing away 30
seconds yeah
yeah I was just wondering that Jordan's
been sitting and enjoying the chess
action with the fact that he took such a
long thing definitely surprising but we
do see he has invited the Marshall oh
are we gonna see a martian
oh no board the most drawing drawish
opening in chess yay
but A4 yeah that's quite the sideline
I've actually never seen that move I
feel like when Mike takes on D5 white
takes on E5 99 of the time really every
time bro yeah A4 is definitely a
different one here and of course if you
guys want to look at some of course I
always got the chance of books always
hit me up I can tell you where
everything is there's a Jan Gustav and
has probably some of the greatest work
I've seen on the Marshall with some
newer things in there and A4 I don't
think was in there it might be but it
might be like all the way in the back of
the book where uh the sidelines are but
yeah Marshall is very fun to play A4 not
too familiar at all yeah the default
reaction I think is to play B4 but that
week in some of the light squares on the
queen side that's definitely not the
only response you can also Play Bishop
B7 of course the direct threat that A4
poses is a takes B5 and you cannot
recapture the pawn because the rook in
the corner will hang Fabby will
definitely play them with H6 improving
his king size structure and miss the
fact that the Rook is hanging that is
how this match is going to end
yeah I myself had this position against
Magnus Carlson just a few weeks ago and
I took on E5 we went down a drawish line
a lot of theory there I think it's been
exhausted everyone studied everything
there and it's been worked out so Jordan
uh who's worked with Magnus of course he
knows his stuff A4 really interesting
and
I think I've seen it I used to play the
Marshall a lot when I was younger
um it wasn't recommended back in those
days partly because of Bishop B7 I also
remember Bishop E6 being a move just uh
there are some tactics some tricks
against this bishop now that the white
apron has moved it can be loose in some
variations but either way a complicated
line and we await to see whether Fabiano
is prepared Jordan coming up with the
first surprise of the game and the first
threat of the game Pawn takes Pawn as
you mentioned but okay Fabi does react
in the end with the most natural looking
move developing a piece he's protecting
his rook in the corner we'll see those
Rooks disappear from the board black had
to recapture with his Bishop the black
queen is needed in the center of the
board to protect the knight uh in the
middle now the question is does Jordan
get greedy and grab that pawn no
Marshall Gambit declined he's just uh
trading pieces he's just opening up
squares for his own kind of queen side
pieces that are faster sleep to Spring
out into the game so it looks balanced
maybe Jordan has a surprise later on
uh David you're talking about Jordan's
pieces on the queen side that look like
they're fast asleep I'm gonna dress the
elephant in the room thus Jordan look
like he's just woken up
chess players do tend to be nocturnal
night owls pretty sure it's like uh 7
P.M where he's living right now so I'm
hoping he didn't just wake up I've
overslept to 5 PM engagement before so
it has happened in the history of chess
players the generate chess players so
chess players
chess players need to Peak normally
later in the day like the afternoon
evening when games happen so they do
tend to like their sleep I know Magnus
uh once told me that he tries to time
waking up until about two hours before
the round starts so that's uh for six
hours after waking up he's peeking at
the right time in the game when the game
is really hitting its climax so these
things do go through the minds of chess
players they don't just wake up late for
no reason not just because they're lazy
because they actually think it will help
improve their performance when it really
matters and we should also address this
last move Tanya Queen to D3 wow not
automatically capturing the D4 Pawn a
nice little tactic there because the
Knight on D5 is spin down so black can't
really run away with the D4 Pawn I like
to move it also does threaten an
eventual attack on the long diagonal you
could set up a battery David really nice
subtlety there by Jordan yeah he goes
the other way I was also inclined
towards a king side attack like you on
this diagonal the white Bishop could
have dropped back but I guess it's
blocked off quite simply by Black's Pawn
pushing no more tricks on this diagonal
instead you wouldn't grabbing this Pawn
so uh level material once more but the
question does remain how does black deal
with this loose Knight to the center of
the bud it's attacked Now by The Queen
by the bishop no time I think to go and
capture this one not too many squares
you have to go back this way or this way
with the Black Knight what do we think
James Daniel what is Fabi gonna do here
oh this is already still some spicy
stuff here I mean they've got Knight E7
what's wrong with 97 yeah I'm trying to
figure out the same thing like what it
feels like something's wrong with it
maybe Knight G5 Queen H5
I think win H5 might actually be
unpleasant with Knight G5
why not G6 here
not a stupid question at all I'm not
wondering that too I don't even know the
answer to that question Tanya I'll tell
you more
Queen at six I've got Knight F5
beautiful and then Queen H3 maybe Neo
Queen looks strange
yeah maybe we start in another way it
feels like uh as you are both mentioning
that just F7 is a bit weak H7
potentially a bit weak as well but uh
how to take advantage I'm not so sure
maybe you start with the Knight you
mentioned this one as well Dania just a
hint of some threats some hits on the F7
Square either way it's complicated how
deep does Jordan's preparation go
How Deeply has he home cooked this light
yeah I looked this up and queen D3 had
actually been played heavily in what's
called correspondence chess that's a
form of Chess where you have usually
several days to make each move and in
modern correspondent chess engine use is
encouraged so a lot of top players some
people in the chat might know this they
rely heavily on the correspondence chest
database because the players especially
at the top of correspondent chess in the
opening they really go after it they
come up with some of the greatest
Novelties some of the most well thought
out ideas in well-known opening so Queen
D3 only correspondence chess has
featured that move when you have that
feeling but you see 10 games and all of
them are correspondence chess you start
salivating oh I found a line in my
opponent might not know right and if you
see a game that was won by either side
it correspondence yes that's like gold
dust once in a million years yeah
anybody over 2400 correspondence loses a
gamer like I'm playing that line
what are your thoughts have you guys uh
ever indulged have a dabbled in
correspondence chess I have never
dabbled in it myself but I am a fan of
just creative chess I look at the blinds
I like playing with the engine like I've
even Fabi I've even seen Fabi do this
where you know sometimes he's looking at
a line and he likes to choose you know
all the way down what's move number four
on the engine that you haven't actually
looked at that's still equal and it
looks good and you can take it with your
opponent out of something they probably
haven't looked at before well yeah I
haven't played correspondence chess but
to experience the level Shonen high
level correspondence chess all you have
to do is play a title Tuesday so you
know so I've done that and Jordan has
put a bishop on G5 excellent move I
think same type of idea right encircling
the king side but removing a critical
Defender that Bishop on F6 without it
the king looking even more like the
emperor without clothes yeah
he needs to make sure he has uh some
kind of attire on uh some kind of outfit
that black king because taking this
bishop now looks suicidal to me I don't
think you can uh even dream of capturing
this white Bishop it might look like the
most natural move but if you take it you
and invite the White Knight forward and
Calamity is about to happen on the F7
Square the White Queen is going to join
the attack
uh yeah I don't want to touch this one
with a 10 foot pole but instead it would
make sense maybe to move the knight uh
this move was the first one on my mind
just to trade off at least now you get
the queen out to the defense I'm a bit
scared I'll lose a pawn somewhere in the
process in the center but for now
everything's covered for black the night
nicely guards the king the queen and
sits nice and pretty
any other choices for Fabby here
I like Knight G6 too I mean the threat
is Bishop takes F6 defend the threat we
don't want to take there it is yeah
Knight G6 is very easy move to make you
also get the Knight closer to the king
side you see this a lot in Italian games
too when they go like knight uh C6 over
to E7 over to G6 but Knight Stone C6 is
still there but tonight on G6 here we
can actually swing into F4 at some point
and that Bishop on A8 is going to be
able to help us out in some type of
attacking chances especially if we land
a knight on F4 in many cases I mean
let's say Bishop F6 Queen F6 get a
knight to F4 you even have Knight H3
possibilities just uh playing playing
around or even Knight G2 sacking and
then moving the Knight I mean there's
this could get sick very very fast for
black it could be black attacking
instead of white easy nice move that
from Fabi and you wouldn't need
something now otherwise things could
well turn
like solid for black I think we're gonna
bail out quickly now after Bishop F6
Queen F6 you could stick the white
Bishop on D5 of course the dream was to
sack on F7 at some point but you know in
that situation with Black's Knight
jumping into F4 Jordan has to identify
the moment when okay you had some nice
preparation you had some pressure but
you don't just want to throw this game
into the trash just because fabby's
managed to neutralize I think we might
see Bishop F6 and Bishop D5 if the other
pair of Bishops gets traded very high
probability that will get something like
a symmetrical position and
magic trick disappearing pieces yeah
exactly and everything off the board
looks very likely and often that's just
top level chest in a nutshell these days
and correspondence chess it's just yeah
you're neutral 2600 FM chess
exactly you just well your both sides
are well prepared all the pieces come
off the board you find all the best
moves and a draw is after all the most
likely result in chess in general so
logical stuff from both sides both
knowing what to do
Jordan just testing Fabi but fabby's had
all the answers so far
opening there by Jordan Barn forest for
the first game with the white pieces but
Fabi up to the task takes his time finds
the precise way to respond sabi's just
been on fire off late he had an
incredible run in the adjustable Masters
he lost to Hikaru in the Grand Final but
was undefeated throughout and then this
event as well we've seen some amazing
chess including the very last match
against Jules musad
he just is fresh out of a victory from
the Romania grandchester is Fabi playing
some of his best Jess these days that
we're seeing from him absolutely I mean
of course Fabi is uh he even you know
made it even I think to the finals
before losing to Hikaru in the last one
so playing so good I mean Fabi is even
in his Blitz chest and his rapid you see
him online now of course at one point
they were like yo his Blitz sucks right
Fabiano as strong as he is but nowadays
oh yeah Fabi is at the top of everything
right now I mean with the likes of
Magnus and icaro the best you know Blitz
fast players on the earth we have a move
here too by the way Queen F5 what is
that was not looking at that one
no there's no middle but that might be
after Bishop C2 James
yes yes
Knight ce7 does actually come to mind
great to open up the diagonal for the
bishop and then Queen where you have
Bishop takes F6 with mass simplification
that's gross
but at the end after white takes on D4
black will not be able to recapture
because of the check on the eight that's
not Checkmate the problem is just that
you lose the bishop why is the evil bar
okay now it's if you take them before
you lose yes now if you refrain from
capturing on D4 you can probably hold
this position just with a move like King
f8 and probably White's extra Pawn is
just too weak to afford any serious
winning chances Knight F4 could also
come to the rescue so this is not
unlikely if Fabby goes 97 but he's gonna
invest some time here because you don't
want to shake the Hornets that's too
much on the king's side wow it's
actually a clever move he always finds
these clever moves here yeah
yeah I don't know I know Ariana
wow 97 would be a fun move with so many
pieces hanging opening up that Bishop on
a targeting the F3 Knight hitting the
queen on F5 and of course the bishop on
G5 is also loose Sabi going into a bit
of a tank the one thing that has been
very impressive about Jordan we've been
talking about the big strands for Fabi
Jordan on the clock every single match
this event has had a Time Advantage oh I
didn't notice that actually that's a
great call there I mean he's he's
prepared and creative and like he's
getting positions he likes besides the
last game with norterbeck where he just
blunder Queen C2 93 oh my goodness right
hurts but of course it happens right
there and you can't miss but he is
getting hit positions he's like
creativity in there making you think a
little bit more and he's thinking on
your time which is very important he's
very focused so thanks a lot on your
time so he moves a little bit quicker
when you are making your move there oh
time on Fabi that's a good thing in fact
good move too as well Queen F5 is a very
interesting move
that's some great chess schedule advice
David of to think in your opponent's
time yeah definitely I think all of my
best Tournament results have been when
I'm thinking during my opponent's time
over the board for example just sitting
in your chair is uh it's a difficult
skill to master it's so tempting to walk
around admire other games but you lose
focus that way well the Soviet
Grandmaster Alexander kotav who authored
a very famous book called think like a
grand master I think in the 50s some
people in the chat might be familiar
with it he actually suggested he said it
was an integral part of the Grand Master
mindset to think more generally on your
opponent's turn
try to make General observations out of
the position think which pieces you want
to trade and then on your turn you do
the more concrete calculation so he
recommended really not getting up from
the board more than a couple of times
and the good thing about playing on the
computer I actually have gotten up from
the computer before just because I have
such an urge to walk around I'm a Pacer
right if I'm on the phone I'm pacing
around the whole house but it's you know
it's easier to sit there and lock in
that's both with both of these players
are really known for doing
yeah and that was advice given to me as
well by Michael Adams the longtime
English number one he was like why are
you walking around you're always in time
trouble you lose extra minutes on your
clock I'm turning up later games you're
like walking around you're barely
thinking and I was like wait you're
right now I've come across uh the reason
and yeah my results improved a lot when
I kind of
but difficult to do so difficult to do
so and fabi's buying this position and
he doesn't make the move Knight
retreating hitting that what a move but
a slide of the queen to the queen side
hitting the bishop instead
it impressed you a lot uh Daniel
um what's going on here that's such a
difficult move born of very subtle
observations you have to notice that the
bishop on B3 is an undefended piece I
didn't that didn't occur to me at all
now if white plays the obvious mode
which I think is Bishop takes F6 after
Queen takes B3 White's Bishop is gonna
have to bounce off of F6 the B2 Pawn is
hanging and Fabi is just calling
Jordan's Bluff Jordan just doesn't have
the Machinery to exploit black sweet
King I would even hesitate to call it a
weak King because it's surrounded by the
rook and the Knight I'm really impressed
by that move
really nice they say lpdo loose pieces
drop off and this is a case where you're
not necessarily winning but you're using
the fact that this is a loose piece
undefended uh unprotected just to get
out of danger with the black queen to
gain time and not just as this bishop
undefended uh the pawn behind it sorry
right the point behind it is also up for
grabs potentially in some variation so
yeah you're calling the bluff you're
saying no actually the black king is
safe as anything and uh counter-attack
begins I think it might be time for
Jordan to try and bail out to try and
simplify this position if he can towards
the draw just in case it becomes too
late
that was really good
nice move really good maybe Knight b2d2
here right I mean maybe just develop I
mean that piece is not moved yet does it
get the piece off the back rank takes
takes F6 is still on pre there so you
have to take maybe on G5 but maybe he
has 97 now that's probably his idea I
still got 97 now after that wow it's
getting spicy yeah very murky Waters in
this position of course white would love
to send that H Bond down the board H4 H5
H6 but that's hard to do because after
Knight bd2 you might have to sack the C3
Pawn oh I don't envy I'm glad I'm in
this warm studio in the commentator's
chair right now this is where I'm the
most thankful
eight minutes for Jordan he does have
that time advantage to invest now on
whether he can play for a win if you
want to make a draw there's probably
various ways to do that but uh just by
getting those pieces off the board
waving that magic wand and saying okay
disappear please but uh yeah he wants
more yord and he's very ambitious and
with white in a two-game match it's
essential to at least try at least press
put your opponent under some pressure
[Music]
after Queen takes B3 if you play Knight
takes D4 there might be some Bishop
takes G2 tactics at the end of the line
so I'm not totally sure what Jordan's
intention is here the above our drops
I'm not sure if it's because of that but
I wouldn't want to allow the full
dissolution of my kingside font
structure black is definitely in the
driver's seat here very easy to miss
because you're so fixated on the B2 Pawn
being hanging yeah just to show this
King takes walks into a nasty Royal Fork
king and queen and uh yep you lose a
piece so yeah easy easy to miss this one
and the fact that he's paused out to
Queen takes B3 when he initiated this
trade
worrying signs for Jordan what else
Bishop takes porn maybe maybe taking
this direction just to keep this bishop
closed temporarily first he hits the
black queen very logical with Knight D2
I'm guessing Queen takes Pawn is fine
does he just want to play Bishop takes
D4 and sign the score sheets yeah
so the reason we say score sheets is
because this is just dead level uh
symmetrical pawns on the king side three
versus three this bishop looks nice and
strong but can't do too much on its own
and everything is protected for white
these two will later get traded the D4
and C7 ports there was a regular 2100 at
my local Club growing up in San
Francisco it was a very eccentric
character as Bishop takes D4 has played
and he was known for offering draws in
very unique ways so he wouldn't just say
I offer a draw he'd say want to call it
a day yo what do you say we grab a
coffee down the street and at some point
everybody knew that when he suggested
something like that it meant that Jules
which was his name not moussard but he
was it meant he was offering a draw he
was known also for playing one before
with white and one B5 with black so you
can kind of get a good picture of that
kind of personality
that's what I love about Chester so many
of those personalities quirky one of a
kind
quirky people who play quirky openings
uh yeah opening Choice tends to reflect
personality right that's correct that is
correct here and this personality here
is looking very dull it's looking very
dry very very dry now of course I
actually would probably take black
because of this bishop I mean look how
menacing the bishop is like it is the
greatest piece on the board it is
hitting everything that you have on the
king side and we can maybe loosen some
things I mean even later on of course
this is a very far stretch from here but
coordinating obviously with maybe the G
Pawn pushing G5 G4 opening up that whole
diagonal using the Rook right the
knights are kind of would become
Superfluous from uh devaretsky is a
Superfluous nice I mean you know shout
out to my uncle devaretsky but it's a
it's a lot of a lot of problems here I
think if you can make these Knights move
around a little bit so we'll see what
happens
yeah I would definitely take black feels
dead equal pretty much a draw almost
guaranteed but if anyone's better it
must be black just because of that
Bishop purely
and uh yeah it's not easy to find any
moves for white I was gonna say until he
jumped forward with his Knight
feels a bit loose though this night
moves yeah it's starting to tick on the
back rankers week you would really love
to be able to play H3 with white you
would love to have that in just so you
can play rookie two in this position now
I wouldn't dare play rookie two although
I can't figure out why it loses exactly
if you play Rook D1 then the Knight on
e4 is loose David as you were saying
Rook can come to EA
do I need to say anything other than
that sound effect it's like the
uncomfortable position sound effect
right right
we should mention huge threats on the
board if you could play H3 you'd be very
happy but Knight to H4 is a knife
deflection night takes night now it's
pretty much forced you're uh 24 as well
or you lose everything yeah Knight takes
Knight Queen takes Rook is the problem
now the Knight has been deflected from
the attack and as you say that Daniel
you lose a knight as well so not just
the exchange not just Rook for night you
lose a whole rook in this process a huge
threat on the board really sneaky threat
from Fabi that is just naughty Knight to
H4 now threatened you need to do
something about The Rook it's really
loose the Knight is the only thing
defending it it's all hanging by a
thread
Jordan may be realizing now he should
have found maybe a safer way to get out
of this game and he moves The Rook up oh
this is scary stuff and he checks from
behind look like Checkmate but they can
for now be blocked by a rook Retreat and
look at Fabio though full alert mode he
also feels that this move super loose on
the back crank he he can smell the
tactics in the position but the valvar
seems to say that rookie 3 is accurate
and if Knight H4 I think there might be
Knight F6 check to cover the B1 square
and only then does white recapture on H4
so that might be the Tactical
justification of Jordan's move wow very
clever let's throw that out there David
Knight H4 don't take this one you will
get checkmated on the back rank now a
rook block is no longer protected you
can uh Checkmate anyway but as Daniel
says Knight F6 really sneaky the pawn
captures the knights and suddenly
there's no checks for the black queen
any check on the background is Checkmate
yeah but you can't use this Square
because the queen covers still Queen
takes D4 hard position to evaluate but
not sure if Abby wants to go for this
given that he's got black in game one
might want to err on the side of being
solid
all open up the bad Pawn structure that
pawn isn't worth going after but I think
Knight H4 is what Fabi had in mind till
he realized Knight F6 which is why he's
we saw that quick expression change from
him but now he sees it doesn't seem to
work I'd be very surprised it's very
non-faby to go for material and just
create these weaknesses in the position
I think he might go for Knight H4 it
just feels like a Fabby move he's always
optimistic he's always kind of
oh do you think Jordan spotted that he
must have done right you must yeah
that's not a bluff rookie three
you don't get lucky there and survive
her with a tactic like that one yeah
sorry Tanya yeah and also because uh
before that Knight H4 was a threat which
he guards with Rook E3 so it's
definitely a move on his radar he is
super tricky we've seen the creative
ways in which he finds the defense and
uh really interesting so David you think
that Fabi might go for this idea winning
the pawn James do you think going into
that line opening up the king would be
the move of choice of Fabi here yeah
Knight H4 is very tempting I'm trying to
think it okay there it is it's on the
board we're trying to see if there was
something else though but Knight H4 is
the Moose Knight F6 we going down this
line Jordan see it Jordan reacted did
you see the look on his face he kind of
brushed the hair out of his face like a
nervous tip kind of almost interesting
and he's like oh wait has he missed
something
maybe he's gonna get lucky here because
Knight F6 is that the only way to
survive he's not the only move
well you can play Queen F4 and then you
have to take on F3 with a pawn and that
is the least desirable because then you
also lose the D4 upon and you've got
nothing to show for it Jordan has to
keep his spirits up that is quite the
stroke of luck if he didn't plan this
beforehand
there are indeed other moves to survive
you mentioned one of them Daniel just
retreating the White Queen sliding her
across to E5 makes sense too but either
way those would give black a kind of
structural strategic Advantage not much
but something to bite on
he's got to play night check just drop
that Knight into F6 60 takes Knight H4
and then I may feel like is right it
feels like white is almost mating you
like you right it feels like you're
getting needed right but Queen D4 holds
F6 unbelievable
yeah double attack though whoa H3 giving
up the White Knight was that a mouse
slap oh
my goodness you kidding what an idea
David now black can probably still draw
there by covering on G5 with the queen
but I wouldn't touch that given the pawn
structure wow trapped
what
both players are in such good form it's
honestly just so refreshing to see
Bishop before here might be the Saving
Grace but oh in this position Bishop E4
wow no Queen F4 I think and queen H5 and
queen takes F6 is mate
incredible lines off the board wow I can
guarantee Fabby missed H3 I think all of
us would have missed H3 in this position
genius from Jordan run first you know
who's attacking who back to move on the
one with stage three for me the speed
with which he played with I think H3
could be the move of the day David yeah
yeah I mean the psychological impact as
well look at Fabi starting to shake his
head he spent one minute on this move
he's only got two minutes left look at
the black king if you can't find a
fourth draw here you might well just get
checkmated that's right mate is around
the corner wow Rook G3 Queen H5 Knight
F5 is looking nasty there this is scary
I also have love for the king I can
always run away King H2 and what do you
do right it's very scary right now for
Fabi and he's getting lower on time look
at the time here so yeah Jordan has here
that's what I've been calling him
Michael Jordan van Forest of if he takes
out Fabi in this one this is a very very
scary situation for 5 right now what is
the move okay
that's scary because of Queen H5 and
Rook G3 it's correct me down below two
minutes now
my gosh Bobby sits up perks there perks
up sitting up body language is saying
I'm in trouble I need to find a move
I think Jordan saw
her he picks up so he's seen Bishop
before yeah but Bishop before loses and
he takes on G4 instead and that might be
the way to drop just put the King on G7
and you have a fortress very prudent
defense by Fabby head shake yeah
but this is
it's the only way to hold it's the only
way to try to hold it's a nightmare
night man we're just a minute and a half
on the clock he's thinking well you take
it back with the pawn or the
music so you can go F4 and G5 later
maybe blast open that King go for some
Forks well so Queen takes would have run
directly into Rook G8 and uh I think
black would have been okay there so
actually the double pawns for black on
the file maybe help in building The
Fortress there are no checks anytime
white steps forward with the G Pawn that
will be traded all off I think this one
actually is quite a simple draw and this
is why the top players are so good
defensively they know even when things
go wrong they can bail out to an endgame
or Pawn down or build a fortress they
know exactly when to sacrifice now I
would love to get Black's Bishop round
just to sit in front of the black king
and just kind of curl up into a ball
I don't think the black seaport is going
to survive much longer there we go it's
getting chased down so Fabi just needs
to find good squares for his rook and
Bishop but really classy decision just
when Panic would have set in for most
people to give up the queen and Force
this Fortress I'm saying uh
optimistically no it is uh Jordan might
just stop for a draw here because at
this point you just go d8 D5 D7 D5 D7
and as you said David the pawns actually
soak up the effect of any pawn break
that's actually why you often want to
have precisely this Pawn configuration
also because your king guards all three
pawns at the same time so there are no
targets at all yeah this type of Pawn
structure for black is only really bad
if the opponent has a knight to kind of
jump into the weak squares around but if
your opponent only has the queen here
Brooks also struggle against this type
of defensive Pawn structure of black has
yeah this one is going to end in a draw
yeah crazy starts at a match here this
ends in a draw five he gets white
Jordan's gonna have to be very creative
again what she's doing already right
here they both in good form here we can
have ourselves the potential of a really
an Armageddon it does look that a very
very high Armageddon rate it's just the
best of two match and this is the first
one Jordan he will try to push somehow
the F Pawn down the board do you think
that's an idea that he can look forward
to now the queen defends the Jeep on but
fabi's not allowing it Rook G5 is this a
perfect Fortress
yes 100
just no improvement Rook G6 Rook G5 or
rookie five or G5 I mean it literally
does as long as you don't accidentally
blunder the F1 it's a dead draw White's
King has no Pathways either
now this is a diagram to show kids if
they're trying to learn what is a
fortress what is the definition of a
fortress how do you defend it's one of
these types of positions the opponent
has no way to break through the
opponent's normally up on material but
there's no way to break through with
Checkmate or to create a past Pawn those
are the main two ways to win a game in
chess and white has neither of them here
but David there's a very famous player
who doesn't believe in fortresses in my
chessable course with Magnus I tried to
poke him on that and he was like okay
people took my words out of context they
do exist so uh he has retracted that
statement
so yeah this one is a draw any moment
the funny thing is you could maybe even
sack the bishop on G4 and still make a
draw but those types of positions
actually get very tricky because then
zubsvong enters the equation here you've
got a whole host of waiting moves and
that's just not great just kidding
advice no do not give up that Bishop
completely unnecessary but a good point
you make that even if the bishop was not
there and you're just for a rook for a
queen you still hold these kind of
positions trickier but now as we can see
there is absolutely no progress nowhere
for white to advance the F and the g
pawn and for Fabi wow in a difficult
position he really kept his cool and
found the best way to defend amazing
stuff by both these players H3 I'm still
thinking about that
I would have just resigned in shock out
after age three but uh giving up the
queen that doesn't cross many people's
mind first and to make that decision
that huge practical decision by Fabi
with only one minute left on his clock
yeah really classy
both players yeah it's hard to pick one
now they're just both playing extremely
well just seeing the board they're
seeing these track tactics that's a sign
that a player is in the zone he allowed
out five there but Fabi doesn't even
want to do anything he wants to keep the
status quo
solidarity
yeah just repeating moves I think at
this point it's just a bit of Pride
who's going to offer the draw neither
side really wants to uh kind of be the
first to say do you want to draw please
they're both just uh playing it out till
The Bitter End
Sabi actually has more time than he did
when he gave up that Queen that's how
confidently he's played since then
finding the perfect defensive structure
and he's not even allowing the chance
giving White's King the chance to March
over to the other side of the board
create threats from E7 attack that F6
Pawn keeps everything under control but
now it's a bit of a question because you
have to give something here either The
Rook moves from attacking the G pawn and
he does because F4 is met by a check and
you pick up the F Pawn
I don't think white ever can set up the
correct configuration to push pawns
forward even if you could I'm not sure
that gets anywhere anyway so yeah Fabi
just uh he set up this defense and he's
sticking to it he knows what to do
it's not allowing anything
whoa oh here we go it was for it what on
Earth is he yeah now just Fabi has to
find an alternate configuration I think
Jordan wants to infiltrate down the dark
squares if you play F5 it is a very
tempting move then trouble might Brew
with King D6 and King E7 I still think
it's a draw because black skin can just
chill on H7 and I don't see a single
potential mating score that's actually
how I think Fabi should defend go F5
Slide the game over to H7 and that's it
and Bishop F5 you just march with the
king is that your idea yeah so I would
make sure that all of your pieces are on
defended Square squares defended by
Pawns
yeah Bishop's F5 looks fine to pawn to
F5 for just that final position you
mentioned Dania even if white gets two
or three free moves uh I'm just gonna
put some moves on the board no Checkmate
as you say uh White could sneak behind
but actually this one loses the queen oh
my goodness you could never go any
further this king is nicely protected by
its rook and Bishop and actually we're
headed in this direction oh my gosh I
hope Bobby sees that oh Jordan has to
see that we've seen one Queen trap in
this game and I think that's enough yep
Black's just gonna wait with his Rook on
those uh three squares G8 G6 G4 any
Square that's protected by a pawn and no
way through for white
kids out there is there a way in your
mind to visualize what is the right
Fortress and how to arrive at it
yeah I mean there's rules you can follow
like most of your pieces have to be on
squares defended by pawns you can also
take your opponent's perspective and say
well what are the mating constructions
here the only one is with White's King
on f8 the queen on G7 as long as you
have that square protected you know for
a fact that your opponent cannot make
progress also you're holding G4 it's
going to be a draw momentarily I think
they just agreed
and that's it we do have a result what a
game this was by both Fabiano Carana and
Jordan van Forest game one ends in a
draw they will be playing the final
rapid game and Jordan there he stays I
think that was him analyzing because he
can't also believe the complications
that happened and how easily Fabi
actually created that Fortress uh
Jordan's still looking at the game do
you think Daniel yeah he's probably
reviewing he was doing that after his
game with notorbeck and we saw his
reaction he discovered that a bishop
could have been captured in one move of
course he's also curious about the
opening but Fabi you will have the white
pieces in the next game Fabio with white
in good form dangerous
dangerous chest coming up but Favi with
white pieces but Jordan has been such a
beast in that game one and David I know
you have a lot to pick from but what was
the highlight for you Tanya I think we
just need an action replay of those
crazy tactics what a game it was even
though there were some fireworks on the
board it was level from start to finish
and it was here that Fabi started the
chaos in a level position he was the one
to start the tricks Knight to H4 trying
to deflect the White Knight away you
cannot take remember because of a back
rank Checkmate however your did her come
prepared with a Counter-Strike Knight to
F6 check forcing the black king to open
up lines in front of it and now there
are no checks for the black queen every
checking square is covered on the first
rank Fabi however had prepared Queen
takes Pawn threatening the Knight
threatening a nasty Checkmate from the
corner again on the back rank but Jordan
realized he could just give his King
some air give the king some breathing
space he solved one problem and the
second problem was dealt with after Rook
check he's given up a night and he
realized he could trap The Black Queen
it turned out that this Fortress was a
draw in the end but fantastic play from
both sides
that's stunning just too pretty to watch
that one needs an action replay about 10
times bigger's with that Precision game
one has ended in a draw and this is our
score line there will be one more rapid
game coming up and this time it's
Fabiano caruana with the white pieces
and he played brilliant shots in his
last match with white against Musa can
he do it again against Jordan van Forest
we will find out after the switch break
[Music]
thank you
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only
game-changing Innovations from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play our history defines us
inspires us and pushes us into the
future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
an error focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space
shifting your state with every breath
find your air of clarity now
[Music]
[Applause]
our Meetup Community is constantly
growing we are at 20 000 members and you
can form your own Community your own
group and get going with Meetup in your
city for all the details visit
meetup.com chess and get the chess going
in your community meanwhile we will be
getting the chess going in game two of
this big matchup with a spot at stake
for the Grand Final it's hard to pick
James but who impressed you more in game
one was it Fabi or was it Jordan I'm not
gonna lie Jordan definitely impressed me
there with the uh the creativity which
is of course we see this all the time
like Queen F5 which was strange he
played A4 which is strange Queen D3 was
strange but all correct and H3 as well
all of these moves fabi's definitely
gonna have to be on his p's and q's and
every other letter in the alphabet for
him to take out you ordered David what's
that perfect game of chess
that's the problem with chess like both
play deserve to win but they just
canceled each other out and a draw is
The Logical result if both players are
playing inspired chess like that and uh
this one okay we're off E4 will we see
another Spanish it seems every game
today has had the Spanish opening and
again the Berlin yeah
definitely surprise the Auntie Berlin
Auntie Berlin No End games here but
Jordan it's not his style necessarily to
play the Berlin I know he's done it
already this tournament he must have
prepared it for the chess kid cup
specifically and okay Fabby vastly
experienced of course we mentioned in
this opening he elects for an early
trade Bishop for Knight black has a
slightly ruined Pawn structure but uh
things are closed so Knights do tend to
do pretty well in these positions as
well H3
slower game ahead very slow game yep
slow game of course Spanish torture
right is like it's gonna be slow very
slow chess here every game we've seen in
Roy Lopez besides the last one has been
like very slow and in game-ness and very
slow that and now uh we might see a
little bit of spice hopefully in this in
this game here what you think anything
yeah I mean it really depends on how
black handles this the E5 Pawn does not
need to be defended immediately because
95 can be met with Queen D4 but uh you
you've also seen players Castle Queen
side in these types of positions with
black the old school approach is just a
castle short and then play either Knight
F6 back to D7 or Rook to E8 because
after White Castles you will eventually
have to defend the E5 Pawn so you could
get a very positional battle but if
black chooses to Castle Queen side which
I know Vladimir kremnik has done
um and a lot of top players have done in
recent years this could get super
tactical as well yeah super tactical is
uh quite likely after the bishop will
come out the king will come out uh to C8
try and hide on the opposite flank uh
there's also the other way of playing uh
Daniel here if black Castle is kingside
white has the option maybe of uh going
for a queen side Castle over the next
few moves and uh we could see the night
move out the way the bishop move and
white king tried to hide on this flank I
wouldn't complain if that happens I
don't think any of us would be
disappointed if that happens so it's
very much up to these two players Jordan
at first keeps his options open he
defends the pawn with a bishop Retreat
so he's lost a move with this bishop it
came out it stepped back but at least
the center now has clarified and because
the center isn't locked
it means black does have the luxury of
time the price of each move is slightly
lower and uh Bobby now he brings his
Knight out
for his standard stuff so far I've
played Fabi actually a couple of times
myself on the black side of uh the
Berlin and it's been suffering it's been
torture indeed I really regret choosing
that against one of the world's leading
experts in these structures uh every
time I see this uh type of structure I
just think car Nakamura Magnus Carson
and Fabiana carwana they just seem to
have it every other game against each
other and they know all the plans all
the places for the pieces so well
H6 meanwhile for building flexible stuff
don't think what's your Castle because
black might start throwing some pawns
towards the white king it's a bit of a
waiting game right now right that's
funny it's like a reverse in Italian
you'll see this in the uh with the black
pieces sometimes if you count so early
then G5 happens so really both sides
actually have to kind of wait here I
guess you can see a G4 or a G5 happen if
anyone castles in this situation it's
kind of funny yeah H6 very rare move I
was checking this on the database Ananda
Paul if had a game but everybody was
playing either C5 from black to clamp
down on the D4 Square verb common idea
Jordan could still play it here or
Castle short but Jordan trying to limit
the mobility of White's Bishop well we
see an early G7 G5
let's go girl let's go girl but then
white would Counter-Strike with D4 and
win the game
so no just to show the ideas we're
discussing there White's King has
committed to one flank and it would be
extremely tempting for black to start
throwing pawns towards it which is
usually well Justified but here is one
of the exceptions because white can
strike in the center an attack on the
flank is often well met by an attack in
the center a counter attack in the
middle of the board so that's why Jordan
doesn't go for it just a general tip for
everyone at home instead he chooses to
retreat his Knight but he's keeping his
options open of maybe throwing some
pawns forward later and Fabi takes the
opportunity to re-route reroute reroute
to his Knight to the C4 Square watch out
if black does Castle kingside for a
slower pace of game but white is the one
with the pawnbricks white is the one who
can open the position at his discretion
a bit later on
interesting choice that by Jordan
vanfurst in the last two moves he has
withdrawn back with the bishop to D6
stepping one step back and then now he
takes his Knight back to D7 delaying the
option of King side castling and we were
talking about re-routing the Knight for
white Jordan also has his own ideas in
the position perhaps trying to get that
Knight to that E6 Square from where he
can start jumping on some Central
squares on the board he now does go shot
Castle there is uh there are ideas of F5
in the air but I really like Knight C5
Knight E6 is that a plan in this
position James 95 96 definitely a
playable plan I also like Knight C5 F5
too you know how aggressive I am I just
like just throw everything at him all
the time don't even think twice but of
course 9596 to take over G4 and F4
squares or it's nice nice C5 Pawn F5 is
good as well we do need to figure out
where this Knight goes though because it
does block the bishop and now he moves
it to B6 instead and we have a trade wow
fast moves that's four definitely play
instantly and I'm taking white yeah yeah
unpleasant position for black and you
mentioned David this is not really
Jordan's style and right now this is
playing right into fabulous hands he's
so experienced with he knows when to
push the lever when to push the F fun or
the d-pawn this is looking very unsavory
for Jordan who's also down two minutes
yeah we can tell by the clock times uh
that you mentioned that Dania that
Jordan is uncomfortable every game
pretty much uh in the whole event he's
ahead on the clock but this isn't his
type of position and he's also walked
into his opponent's kind of uh home
territory here so
yeah I do fear for black the good thing
is opposite color Bishops if you can
somehow break out in the center trade
off the knights trade off all the heavy
pieces should be safe but a long way to
go before that and it is quite likely
that white might even be able to whip up
an attack against the black king white
has the semi-open f file now
yeah uh some open F line the White Queen
the white Rooks they're gravitating
towards that black king Natural Healthy
straightforward play Queen G3 Bishop E5
get the other Rook into E1 you're
playing essentially without risk here
for white I'm loving it for Fabby yeah
that's the thing zero risk at all if
things go wrong for white okay you trade
off some pieces you maybe make a draw if
things go wrong for black you just get
checkmated yeah so the stakes are higher
even if the computer might say it's
roughly level here the engine actually
the evaluation Bar says it's quite nice
for white uh but uh yeah either way for
black you're also playing without a
piece he's really misplaced that black
knight uh you were Tanya James you were
talking about that Black Knights path to
kind of fresher pastures now it's kind
of not contributing at all to the battle
I'm not loving that Knight at all and I
think again he has to find a way to
reroute it to try and defend on the king
side because otherwise he will be
playing without a minor piece meanwhile
white also has ideas of provoking more
weaknesses on the king Side by doubling
down on that G7 Pawn notice how the
queen on G3 attacks it a move like
Bishop E5 always in the air forcing
black to play pawn moves and another big
takeaway for chess kids Bon moves means
more weaknesses absolutely and Fabi
trying to find the right arrangement of
pieces you can have you can play a kind
of pass move like Rook a to E1 but he's
trying to squeeze the most out of the
position you could play Bishop E5
to try to provoke some weaknesses so not
so easy to handle white he's picked all
the low-hanging fruit off he's gotten
the queen to G3 but now push has come to
shove and you have to actually find ways
to tighten the screws on the king side
yeah this is where I'm so different from
Fabby Fabby is calculating looking for
the force wind looking for something
direct looking for an immediate tangible
Advantage I would just be playing Rook
A1 because I'm lazy and I wouldn't
calculate I just see one bad piece or
one piece that's not really
participating and I think okay I don't
need to be lonely out there and they
won't just centralize it and if you
compare all the pieces this night more
centralized than Black's Knight this
bishop far superior to its counterpart
looking at both sides of the board the
White Queen active the two Rooks better
than the black Rooks
I think that should be enough for Fabi
but instead he's gone for something a
bit more direct he jumps in with the
bishop this is maybe uh even stronger
what is his next idea
that's the question I don't really want
to trade off this bishop for night
because that black knight is not doing
anything anyway but maybe you're left
with a better minor piece even in that
position
what does Fabi want good question now
yeah maybe just rookie one I mean
improve right Rick a to e and just hope
for the it just improves the piece then
we have to back this bishop up
eventually and the question is where do
we go to E5 provoke an F6 or do we go
back to F4
yeah the bishop
hit the queen but it's just a one move
threat what's the follow-up it's a bit
mysterious to me and also Black's Queen
on D7 it's a move that black perhaps
wanted to make anyway to connect the
rook and to finish development so just
provoking that a bit mysterious what
Fabi wanted out of it and even more
mysterious that he goes into a thing
right after the most natural response by
black
yeah the only explanation I can come up
with is that for example here he might
have wanted to drop his Bishop into a
square such as this one and then kind of
lock it in with a pawn move but he
didn't want to allow Black's Queen to
come out with a trade so uh okay he's
gone the other side of the board
okay very strange stuff I've got to say
from Fabi he just wants to uh whoops he
wants to look down on this night I like
it actually I think I this this makes
sense yeah it makes sense it's just uh
the full board awareness is beyond me
just looking at that side of the Border
sorry that side of the water when I
would have been looking at the black
king yeah interesting stuff abiano
caruana and we've seen that with him
throughout this match that moved Queen
be it in game one again there was a
question about full board awareness you
were looking at all these ideas on the
king side then he goes and attacks the
bishop on the other end of the board and
we're seeing that same freshness by Fabi
here with the movie A4 definitely some
great air quality there where Fabi is
shout out to air things for providing
that data to us so we know how his mind
is so fresh A4 on the board a fresh idea
which we were not expecting in the
studio it has a direct threat you want
to go A5 black doesn't have the
opportunity to stop that because the
Knight on B6 is hanging uh how dangerous
is this Advance on the queen side A5 B4
trying to get more space extremely
dangerous shall we say it is a breath of
fresh air
um these kinds of things are pretty
dangerous for black because if you push
the pawn up to A5 you force the Knight
to drop back to C8 severs the
coordination between black strokes and
then any King side attack is by
definition going to be stronger with a
bunch of blacks pieces out of commission
Jordan can't play A5 himself pointed out
the Knight drops and the move d4 for
black just plays into White's hands
because white wants the Knight on E2
anyway from there it can jump to F4 so
definitely I wouldn't have played either
of those last two moves in a million
years but that's why I'm sitting here
and fabby's sitting there and he might
be on the road to creating some serious
problems for Jordan yeah how does Jordan
make the most of his position here how
does he defend I would want to activate
this Rook at least I don't necessarily
want to attack this bishop yet it feels
like I'm taking a retreat square away
from the Knight imagine later after the
white Bishop Retreat somewhere imagine
if this Knight gets kicked into the
corner a bit like a previous game that
we've seen today that's an H1 1988 don't
try it at home yeah instead I uh I do
assume maybe he's going to choose a
square like this one at least then he
can meet this move with a night
retreaten you mentioned the Rooks being
disconnected if the knights in between
them in the way there we go at least now
the Rooks are connected the Black Knight
is still bad one bad piece but the rest
for black is pretty harmonious and he
plays it Gordon Rook E8 on the board
we'd all take white here I'm assuming oh
yeah everybody's taking away here just
trying to figure out how to use these
dark squares somehow like it feels like
you can maybe Rook lift or you need the
knight in the bishop on the king side
over here with some deadly attacks like
even dropping a piece almost on F6 right
of course those tactics look really nice
you do look for a rook F6 at some point
which would be really nice but you do
need to get the bishop involved so it's
going to take a while like Bishop F4
moved the bishop back play Queen H4 and
Rook F6 it's really but it takes a while
and the ordinance is not going to go for
that too as well he also knows what we
want he may even have an F5 of his own
so it's it's a hard game for sure
okay Fabi does drop back kicking the
black Rook away
King is almost checkmated but no way to
break through as you said James it takes
a while to set up any attack for white
man I hope that Bishop gets a raise
[Laughter]
it's doing all the work in White's
position
it's not clear what it's actually doing
but yeah yeah it's you know it's in the
office it's not sure it's not clear that
that Bishop is actually working Wilson
would approve of that oh my in the
office I timed it wrong I should have
dropped that in yesterday
Knight to C8 note how the white Bishop
dominates the Black Knight but the white
Bishop will get kicked away in the near
future yeah I think rain would probably
play with the Dwight pieces here too
white
have you ever seen the uh the English
office I've never even seen the American
office oh wow
because I've never seen the American
office any uh the original
and for admitting that it probably I'm
probably gonna be kicked get kicked out
of this office
all right I don't know no that's retired
now no no I'll be here all night
I see eight guys yeah
yeah difficult position that's why we're
kind of deflecting with all these puns
just because
we won you know just like whatever get
the last piece in the game
it feels like he's just procrastinating
Fabi rather than taking proper action
he's kind of just moved his Bishop three
times pushed the a pawn
really unclear what he's actually
kind of uh angling for here yeah the
plan is difficult that's the problem
it's like what's the plan right but it
means if you don't have the plan you
improve the position yeah but and he's
been doing that moving the bishop around
Black's actually improved a lot too as
well though I'd love to get the C3
Knight over to H5 the moment is the
moment you play Knight E2 black plays D
takes D4 and ruins your Center you can
waste the tempo on E5 but that's exactly
that you spend a Tempo you allow black
snipe maybe to get into the action with
97 and Knight G6 and man that King on H7
is looking more solid than ever I think
Jordan has done a great job defending
and again his time management has been
excellent he's now up on time he's
looking really really nice here
yeah I like it suddenly for black hole
at least I don't think black is
objectively worse anymore earlier black
had pretty much no pieces in the game no
pieces near the black king now you have
defensive pieces you have potential with
the Black Knight
Abby I think for the first time today
we've seen him play several games
already for the first time today I'm
questioning his uh kind of strategic
choices just using the same piece
several times when you've still got the
Rook on A1 I hope I'm asleep
uh I'm not a huge fan but uh maybe he
has a deeper idea in mind
there we go he trades a set of Pawns and
we didn't really discuss this if black
had captured the other way then black
would have been left with an isolated
Pawn in the center of the board instead
taking with the bishop allowing a knight
for Bishop trade but at least keeping
the black structure intact black has at
least two porn Islands now everything
connected
and okay calm stuff he's just aiming to
stack up and double up his Rooks on the
F line
what do we make of this transition I
mean it's boring just draw I mean it
feels very weak and very like I mean it
can be double edged in a few moves here
but like I mean everybody's solid both
pieces have development I mean I'm also
going to get this night off night off of
C8 I would probably prefer white just by
a little bit because we do have the
opposite called the Bishops in these
in-games or in these games period
obviously color Bishops you know the
attacks can be very brutal because the
other side obviously cannot defend due
to having the opposite color Bishop so
doubling the Rooks and maybe aiming at
H6 and G7 somehow Knight F5 is coming
this does feel very milk toast I mean
you can double on the f file even if you
Force black to play F6 my tactic senses
aren't really tingling there you just
don't have enough oomph going on on the
king side yeah now after all of that the
only way white is ever going to be
better is by crashing through with the
checkmating attack but as you say Daniel
just doesn't feel like you have the
ammunition the Firepower right now for
for white blacks pieces are getting
organized
getting into position
and uh I think oh I don't want to jinx
it but maybe another Armageddon today
we've been treated
that would be the dream because this has
been a fantastic fight between these two
players if this game ends in a draw it's
far from it right now all two results
possible here but we're just the kind of
Chess that you have been playing
absolutely precise and perfect play we
are expecting this one to go down to the
wire and while that happens we're also
waiting for your selfies post them on
Instagram with the hashtag chess Champs
and you could win the air tanks black
with device to help you monitor your air
quality right now in the studio we're
monitoring the play quality and our
commentators think it's been fantastic
that Bishop Retreat to D2 always
stepping out of any night Forks C5 is
black threatening to set up a battery on
the long diagonal
I'm not sure if it's a direct threat but
it's certainly what he wants to do he
would love to preserve his uh beautiful
Bishop black here uh if you could just
step it back somewhere along that
diagonal then it's unclear what the
White Knight will ever do
um yeah I think it's just a very solid
move as well he's hinting at potentially
uh kind of a minority attack on that
side of the board as well he's just
saying okay I'm clamping down your
structure is better on the queen side
you have more pawns there with white so
I'm just going to lock you down you can
never advance
and yeah fabby's stuck he's played all
the pretty moves the piece is all on
nice uh kind of looking squares but
still no plan no threat
yeah it feels like uh both sides are
just waiting for the action to begin and
I would consider Knight D1 Knight E3
Knight G4 maybe to create some semblance
of King side threats just at least to
scare your opponent more Queen H4 also
threatens Rook takes F6 but yet it's
another one move threat that's very easy
to Parry several ways to do it whether
it's Knight G6 or Rook e to f8 and if
I'd be burning a lot of time here and
deciding on a trade a committal decision
which does lead to an imbalance no more
opposite card Bishops for you wow so uh
taking a Really Brave decision because
it looks like the Black Knight is pretty
uh strong here in the center and okay
pushing Pawn to A5 that doesn't feel
like it's too threatening just trading
off a set of Pawns over there I guess
that pawn was attacked on the last move
and uh black controls the main open file
in the position no hits here no tactics
I wouldn't be surprised if Jordan just
starts to double up his Rooks in the
center of the board White's attack
more of a illusion right now
it smells like Armageddon to me bro this
smells just like Armageddon looks just
like uh I mean dead equal dead equal
guys have enough time to figure this out
not blunder anything no real Attack for
whites you can't you don't want to make
any committal moves like pushing C4
which weakens D3 drastically right A5 is
a move we can get away with maybe trying
to open the a file try for some chances
trade a few pieces we shake hands we go
to Armageddon
yeah and uh often for the chess kids out
there we talk about peace exchangers
Rooks coming off the board Queen's
coming off the board if it's just pure
Bishop versus knight
do we still think that's level
yeah I think if all of the Rooks come
off the board it's essentially a dead
draw there's a non-zero possibility of
that I mean white could go rookie one
and start initiating the process if Fabi
wants to keep some spice alive maybe he
can operate on the queen side but a move
like C4 is incredibly committal but D4
this is what I'm talking about whoa and
wants to slide the queen over to D3 pick
up the pawn and maybe use that pawn
majority and attack the B6 Pawn I like
it
yeah I don't think uh well I think
Barbie's happy now I don't think Jordan
should have allowed this it feels like
the more the position opens up the more
it will favor the long range piece the
bishop
so yeah really nice spot there tactical
idea from Fabi I was going to show it on
the board but we're going to see it in
the game the White Queen slides across
check the black king Force back and uh
material balance restored the black
Knight's still looking nice and strong
but suddenly a bit less stable in the
center of the wood
let's see if on can March up to C4 and
hit that night it is a very different
position after that D4 move and then
again we talk about these Pawn
structures that little move by Jordan F6
has created some weaknesses on the
king's side but that's why we have
enough pieces imagine if uh for Fabi
instead of a dark Squad Bishop you can
trade that for a light Squad Bishop in
this position it's a completely
different game because then you can
really take advantage of those light
squares but right now not so easy but I
still think the advantage here if for
anyone It's gotta be for Fabi with
sacrifices on H6 a potential Queen Side
Pawn Star creating a passer anyone can
try it looks like it's Fabby is that
accurate or do you think the Knight can
be tricky really enough I think he
created some very nice chances here in
the next last few moves here I mean if
we can get the bishop like to C3 and
then Rook takes F6 is on top six
H6 exactly that's what we're looking at
right now here guys yeah very sick
tactics are available now that we've
made that uh that imbalanced after
trading there pushing D4 he made some
real threats happen I mean that's crazy
how Fabi was able to create these type
of threats in the position that we had
literally like two moves ago
very nice yeah maybe a direct threat as
you mentioned Pawn to C4 kicking the
Black Knight away uh we just showed what
happens if the Black Knight does retreat
it becomes crazy white has all those uh
tactical shots and okay Jordan brings
this Rook across one Defender away from
the King giving the king some breathing
space
is that it feels shaky somehow I would
go see four and B3 maybe engine says
everything is good so C4 right I guess
except that oh 93. that's why okay nice
one
I think it's catchers we need to prevent
it but then you allow rookie too so
needs to be careful this Fabby here yeah
maybe it's just a strong move from uh
Jordan just relocating improving a piece
actually we advise that quite often so
why did I hesitate it's just the blacks
pieces are a bit loose but wow Fabi he's
thinking long term now the bishop versus
knight uh kind of configuration suits
him so he's trying to get rid of some of
Black's most active pieces that black
rook in the center holding everything
together logical move I quite like it
for white this last one
so any end game in this game would mean
Advantage big Advantage Fabi as he would
be the one who'd create a parcel on the
queen side and with that Bishop
assisting that things would be very
difficult to hold the more pieces that
get traded the better it is for Fabi one
Rooks off Knight goes back to E7 hitting
that Rook the C2 Pawn is still a little
tender does black have some tactics to
try and take advantage of it centralize
your Queen Once The Rook falls back yeah
if there are any tactics we know Jordan
will find them he showed that today and
wow
Brave stuff going for blacks lone porn
on the queen side
ambitious but he's left his King
undefended the white king now a bit
loose Tanya you mentioned some tactics
the White Sea porn now that is eyed up
by The Black Queen and Black Brook
how to defend that Bishop C3 maybe looks
good I was thinking could also put the
pawn on C3
but then
wow there's even like Knight G6 and
Knight H4 ideas so Jordan I mean again
the Queen of the Night that's been a
theme of this tournament and there we go
and ig6 on the board and Jordan is
starting to flirt with perhaps playing
for a win especially given fabby's clock
time yeah that Knight is undefended but
don't get greedy don't go and grab it
with the White Queen the White Queen was
needed to protect its Rook so uh he's
really staying consistent with his
strategy here Fabi he's tried to trade
off the Queens he knows any end games
will favor the bishop because black has
a weak Pawn because there are pawns on
both flanks so uh Jordan wants to run
away with this but not many squares to
use for the black queen
is he gonna try and sacrifice a pawn he
loves to sacrifice spawns uh you're the
van Forest but is this one of those
moments I don't think he should allow a
queen trade no again I mean the queen is
centralized too so maybe we just go
Queen C7
step back one square with the black
queen then Bishop E3 could maybe move it
with a rook to d8 and it suddenly things
get very tactical with whites King
subject to that check on the first ring
that would drive it out to F2 that's the
last thing he wanted for Fabi but a big
decision either way here for Jordan
yeah practical terms I think you have to
gamble you have to keep the Queens on
and hope you can whip up some counter
play against the white king just uh any
end games will be miserable and white
will have zero risk it's only black
playing for survival if the Queens come
off so I think Jordan he'll be missing a
trick if he doesn't keep the Queens on
right now
big decision for him he's got an extra
minute on the clock that also points
towards keeping the Queens on the board
Black's King is safer has more Pawn
protection than the white king
I think he's got to do it step back he
takes he takes he goes for the train B3
and C4 and you could fall into a
miserable position here really really
fast I don't like that call by Jordan
it's also much easier position to play
with weight than time pressure he should
be able to hold this with best play but
I would hate to have this against the
super GM
I think he was too caught up with the
result there Jordan he was happy to try
and guide the game towards a draw but
this one is still far from a draw it's
never going to be easy for black anymore
oh I hate that decision I think just a
Miss trick especially Fabi we've seen
him get a bit nervous he did against
Jewel in one of the games when his clock
ticked down
I think he should have played for the
attack there Jordan
big big moments will he regret that
decision Box level as well James yeah
why he just has a you know a preferred
position where a rook is active with
Bishop verse Knight you have the pawn on
B6 which is dark Square I have a dark
Square Bishop right and we also can
maybe end up walking the king up we can
also play C4 Bishop C3 attack tonight
Bishop D4 and we have the pass pawns
we're gonna push forward here but it has
to be very precise and time is getting
low for both
yeah time's getting low the kings are
coming however towards the center
Black's Pawn has been locked down again
great strategy white has a DOT squared
Bishop so he's put all his pawns on the
light squares so the light squares are
covered by the pawns the bishop does
work around those and okay kicking away
the Black Knight no good squares for
that night right now yep nice move and
the Knight has to lose contact with the
B6 spawn now you could trade Bishop D4
and Rook B5 is already a decisive threat
so black will have to quickly run that
night maybe to E7 and C8
yeah and that's why Fabi very patiently
brings this King up because you don't
win this game in one move you win this
game by posing threats and trying to
catch your opponent in an awkward setup
Knight F4 Anyway by Jordan as he tries
to defend actively force that Rook off
of the center
no no white Rook has two options it
either slides across the board to
pinpoint that black B Pawn or it goes up
the board maybe cutting off the black
king
different strategies here Fabi has to
choose you have to maybe be a bit
careful if you go to the wrong square
with the white Rook you might get forked
you might walk into the black bee Pawn
stepping forward the white Bishop not on
a safe Square so this one's still
tactical despite the fact it is an end
game and it's always the case right when
one side has the Knight because it's
always jumping around and these Forks
are always there on the board we were
talking about how all of white spawns
are on light squares also notice how
black spawns are actually on the same
color as fabi's Bishop which gives him
easy target as Daniel Luber mentioning
that B6 Pawn a big weakness once you can
just get out of these tricky checks with
the Knight Bishop D4 Rook B7 is a big
idea on the board and at some point
maybe the G and the H Pawn can start
advancing imagine a break on G5 and
suddenly G7 is tender
yeah white would love to start creating
cancer kind of creating action on both
sides of the board but instead black is
the one to create a threat nice kind of
agility there from the Black Knight
threatening to jump towards the white
pawns on the queen side white would love
to teleport the king over to protect
those pawns right now but it's not quick
enough James hmm yeah not quick enough
indeed but I am liking white still I do
like my chances but I mean he could play
King f8 King E8 but how do you stop
Knight C5 good question I think you
might have to go Bishop before and trade
on C5 and that basically means that's
basically all she wrote
wow did you go for it Knight to C5
big take and Armageddon oh my God is
this a draw
I think so Black's Rook is just like at
this point yeah most likely if you could
teleport the white king forward somehow
just to D5 to C3 to protect this Pawn
you'd be loving life but I don't think
you're quick enough still you take white
but should be a draw now with best play
you can't create a passport without more
trades pawns are disappearing stroke B6
I think is maybe even the simplest
and someone's gonna offer a draw here oh
my god oh they'll just find a way to
repeat this position Rook B3 the pawns
have been traded off and we are
expecting this one go down to the
Armageddon well there are it's two was a
three on the king side Fabi does have
the C passer anyway that that can be a
danger point for black hair Rook check
advanced upon how diff is it easy to
hold this position as black
Friday this thing it's Magnus I'd be
pretty nervous but I had to be nervous
in a rook versus Rook position so the
answer is yes
I'd be nervous with King versus King
against Madness
he's pushing he's got H5 on the board
clamping down the king side so no
repetition black will still have to earn
the draw
yeah and everyone at home should note
how Jordan is going active with the
black king never sit passive never get
your king cut off on the back rank in
Rook end games the king is an important
active piece and he's allowing actually
white to win a pawn white can go and
grab the black G Pawn but black will be
selective there I think this one is uh
guaranteed to be a draw at this point
it's very cleanly see the best defense
and offense is behind the pawn here so
if it's uh my white Rook would like to
be behind the Palm but it's in front and
the black Rook is ideally placed for us
to take this Pawn H5 could also hang too
if you're not careful so yeah this
should be absolutely a draw here King F5
active King
yep active King White's passport and is
kept under lock and key by the black
Rook behind as you mentioned there James
and the white Rook has actually rendered
passive because it's stuck defending
it's so important the one thing you
should be wary of here with black is
kind of crossing over to the G file you
don't want to allow the white Rook to
move away with check and allow the pawn
to keep stepping up the board he'll be
slightly careful so Jordan yeah he keeps
his King on the Square it cannot be
checked by the white Rook nice play so
active all the time all his defense is
based on offense
Jordan just never goes passive in any
position now he's flat he's threatening
to further drive down the white king
with a check on C2 meanwhile white could
go for the G7 pawn it doesn't really
help the cause you can win upon on the
king side but Black's King is Super
Active if this goes into an Armageddon
is there a favorite in this match nope I
can't even give a favorite there I mean
this chest has just been completely
equal very creative with uh Jordan but
also you know calculating machine
preparation from Fabi they meet each
other and it's been a draw each time so
far but then maybe James it comes down
to who gets black who gets the black
pieces that's right this is very crucial
Abby's still trying by the way I mean if
you wanted to draw he could have offered
it or taking on G7 he's squeezing every
last drop out of this position he wants
to take on G7 and go Rook G6 the problem
is even if he does all of that black
just steps into F4 with his King I mean
this is this is easy clap for Jordan
yeah the only thing that can stop him
now from getting the draw is nerves
Jordan I think if he overthinks the
position perhap s perhaps things might
slip but
it's hard to imagine too much going
wrong even if he just sits tight even if
he just kind of wait with the black Rook
I don't see too much happening there
but he will want to find the active
defense it's your defend first he wants
to find the most forcing way the most
active way I've never seen him sit
passive in any position ever Jordan so I
didn't even have fire waiting yeah
on the spot there nice can you two Rook
moves
right on Q F5 let's take swap those
pawns riveting position
and Rook G6 one last strap and black and
play Rook D6 track but he takes on F5
okay that's it yeah yeah everything's
just coming off the board now this game
is going to be drawn in the next few
well next few seconds I was gonna say
next few hours a few hours it's
definitely neutral now
I play Rook G6 and everything will walk
the king to the corner
yep they disagree that's it and the
second game ends in a draw which means
we are going into the bidding Armageddon
Fabiano caruana there he doesn't have
reasons to be too displeased about it it
was an even game both players once again
coming out with a precise play and
active defense there Jordan van Forest
playing some excellent chess today it's
not gonna be easy for Fabi and we in the
studio feel that it all will come down
to who will get the black pieces in that
bed and how low are you willing to go
for the black pieces but David in the
rapid portion as James said hard to pick
a favorite because both just played
amazing chess both played great chess
attacking when they could but also
decides on the defense always found the
Right Moves the level of accuracy the
level of precision was off the charts
here and uh just when we were getting
excited about Fabiano caruana's chance
chances to win this game Jordan found a
really nice defensive maneuver first he
activated the Black Knight active
defense the best form there kicking the
white Rook away but now this move the
backwards night move really nice really
classy remembering that these white
pawns are actually slightly vulnerable
the big threat of course is Knight to C5
a double attack hitting the white rook
and hitting these pawns and it's because
of the weakness of this Pawn that white
was forced to trade his Superior Bishop
for the Black Knight we saw Knight C5
land on the board the trade happened
here and everything disappeared in the
end of The Rook end game did follow the
cliche it was a draw
big chest uh okay take away there always
always look for active defense and
that's exactly what God Dutch number two
over to the Finish Line in the rapid
both games ended peacefully but the
games themselves were anything but
peaceful it was dramatic chess all
around and with that we are in for a
treat and as we see these two monsters
will be fighting it out in the
Armageddon as we wait for the Armageddon
bids we are going to go into a twitch
break for our non-subscribers for those
of you who are subscribed with us stay
right where you are we've got something
special coming up foreign
[Music]
Jordan man Forest is we've seen him play
incredible chess he is the Dutch number
two the 2021 winner of the Tata steel
Masters he's up against one of the best
in the world well number six Fabiano
caruana and he's been showing some
inspiring chess and there's another
player who's been playing inspiring
chess and he's just all of 14 just
unbelievable stuff a super talented
chess kid he's from England
International Master shreyas Royale and
he's got a dream to be the youngest
Grandmaster from England from England
David had a talk with him take a look
I think when I was five six years old I
said I want to be a Grandmaster
getting the title uh The Grandmaster
title but also being the youngest to do
it in the UK that was a huge goal uh it
drove me throughout my entire entire
childhood it was all I could think about
at times
[Music]
my friends they would be out playing
football out you know hanging together
and I would just be at home studying
chess playing chess whenever I could and
it was all with that one specific title
in mind so when I got it it was just I
mean the feeling was incredible I yeah I
ran back from the tournament Hall to
meet my mum she was crying with joy it
was uh yeah it was amazing I felt that I
had kind of paid some of what my parents
had sacrificed bringing me around the
world around the country every weekend
the record has been mined for 16 years
but I'm about to lose it
how are you nice to meet you
I'm currently thinking about The
Grandmaster record uh which Connie
stands I think at 16 years and one month
old by the man who's sitting right
opposite me I would be the youngest
English Grandmaster if I were to get the
title before then and I'm currently 14
years old so I think I have pretty high
chances I could try to get it this year
I don't know how many records I've held
but this would be probably my biggest
one so far
[Music]
I got into chess through my father at
the age of six he taught me the basic
moves and then I went to my local
primary school and they had a chess club
there I guess my first major achievement
was when I was seven years old I was
feeling very happy
I felt I was good at something
and I was better than a lot of other
people but Justice's chess career was
starting out his future life situation
became uncertain shrez was essentially
Britain's chess hope and his father was
here on a work visa that work visa was
running out and essentially he was going
to be deported the people in the country
the English Chess Federation they didn't
exactly want to lose me I was also you
know really used to England I liked
being here I had a lot of friends I also
wanted to stay and I guess English Chess
Federation and my family and some more
important people also fought for my case
we launched a PR campaign to try and
keep tours in the country which gained
an enormous amount of attraction in the
end we got an unexpected call from the
home office saying that our Visa has
been extended it felt pretty good I even
got the British passport so whenever I
traveled to tournaments like in use the
British passport and skipped the long
lines recently shreyas Royal started
working as an ambassador for chess kid
this tournament sponsor helping others
learn the game
I'm really happy to be working with
chess kid to help get more players in
the UK playing chess and do some shows
with them and I play every week on chess
kid for against some of the players on
the side let's do this okay three two
one
[Applause]
hand behind my back
okay
38 seconds okay but I have to mention
there was one rule that you did not
follow no just to take one piece at a
time
three two one go
oh 46 seconds I did 38 oh but I was a
bit I was a bit naughty in the way I did
it well done
so David how would you feel about losing
the record it's about time it's been too
long I've held on to it too long so I'm
glad that someone is about to take it we
have a bunch of young teenagers now who
are breaking through and if I could be
the wise old man kind of supporting them
helping them along then I'll Embrace
that role we want to be a top class
Grandmaster hopefully 27 50-ish and
that's pretty much my main goal I have a
feeling we'll see him in the top hundred
of the world within a few years and from
there it's up to him whether he can hit
the next level if he really dedicates
himself to chess
explain a story overcoming difficulties
and challenges with ambition and hard
work David how cool is it that you've
inspired so many youngsters in England
I'm so proud of that yeah I mean if the
only way I've inspired them is to come
and take my records then then my job is
done but yeah it's so nice to see the
young players and it's actually really
kind of reinvigorating for me as well
just to see that hunger their drive and
their parents are doing a great job too
they've got great support networks and
they are the future after all so uh the
chess kids out there yeah keep up the
good work
just amazing stuff but just kids across
the world inspiring all of us in the
studio and we're also seeing inspired
chess in division two and division three
as always our eyes and ears for the
other two divisions Simon Williams he's
joining us in our studio Simon what's
the big news
yeah lots of action we're getting very
near to the Grand Final in both division
two and three which will happen tomorrow
and uh let's just have a quick look at
the results as they're being coming in
today so there's two brackets remember
in each division there's the winners
bracket and the losers bracket the
winners bracket are players who have won
every single match and you can see feta
served there is into the Grand Final but
his opponent
um has dropped down to the losers uh
final and then you can see that Mama
jarov is been through to the losers
final by beating adri aching and we keep
moving through with division two here
and that means that Mama jarov then
played against new Young who lost that
match before so mamajarov is now playing
in the Grand Final against fedexv so
that is what's going to happen tomorrow
and that is gonna be one brilliant match
because both of these players are
incredibly strong and they're both very
exciting players and whoever wins that
one goes through to division one now
division three the losers final we had
Harry Krishna play against in playing
still against the young Dennis lazovic
and whoever wins this one goes through
to the Grand Final against uh picture of
Argentina who won yesterday in secured
his place there so it's the final day
all round tomorrow and if you win
division two you get 10 000 and a place
in division one if you win division
three you get five thousand and a little
clap from me as well
for especially that little clap
everything to play for and wow what a
dream final there Daniel with big fish
against the shock I mean better safe has
just impressed me
so much he's had very tough pairings
thus far such a good rapid and Blitz
player very excited to watch the final
more excited to watch the division one
grand final but chess fans of all the
entertainment they could possibly ask
for including an Armageddon coming up
right now
the clocks are ticking and we are
waiting for the beds and they are ready
let's reveal the bids by the oh my God
Jordan Barn Forest wins the bid with
three seconds and he chooses white and
we have never seen that happen
wow it shows white there that is crazy
I'm not sure he's chosen the colors but
uh yeah the time that he's chosen he's
definitely been watching because earlier
today Fabiano against your Musa chose 9
minutes 58. so to go five seconds lower
that's great strategy we are getting a
confirmation that you're in one Forest
he won the bed and he has chosen white I
chose white unbelievable which means
that he has to win on demand I'm baffled
I'm choosing black every single time you
get two for one like it doesn't make
sense the average who's white really but
that's his decisionary very creative
player maybe he has something up his
sleeve yeah I mean it's one of those
things right if he loses everybody's
gonna criticize him how could you have
chosen white if he wins it'll be a
genius decision I honestly think that
five minutes versus draws that's pretty
fair odds that's why we have Armageddon
in the first place but I am surprised it
is a rare Choice only the course of the
game will tell us whether his choice was
successful we've never seen something
like this happen before a player wins
the bed and chooses to play White has to
now win on demand
wow I'm I'm still getting my header on
this he won the bid by three seconds yep
and we've seen two draws in this match
so far and there they are they're ready
to go yard and one for us David you've
got an expression of Auto shock on your
face right now I'm trying to work out
the rules Tanya I should probably know
this but we've never been in this
situation before with someone choosing
white does that mean he starts the game
with nine minutes no 15 minutes I think
he starts with 15 minutes white always
starts at 15 minutes black starts with
his bit I think or no what that's yeah
that's definitely confusing I'm pretty
sure white starts with 15 minutes at all
times
Sim and black starts with the amount of
time that he bid which is 956.
wow we are going to get a confirmation
on this withdrawads okay this is
unprecedented in the Champions chess
store
it would be absolutely crazy if he
starts with nine minutes no then he
doesn't know that that's absurd no he
starts with 15 minutes I'm positive
what's the point of the
who gets to choose to choose the color
but white always starts with the same
amount of time wow okay I would just bid
14 minutes 59 then just let my opponent
take whatever you want bro take whatever
they fit wow and we see Jordan there
with a very bold decision uh to start
with the white pieces Fabiano Carana
with black will just have to draw to
take the match and there's so much on
the line it is the big spot too the
Grand Final and uh this is just
unbelievable stuff what we're witnessing
right now if Jordan pulls this off
wow it's the move of the year
we're not even talking about the chess
moves
yourself though that's important
like we talk about rules in chess having
confidence in any sport in any game is
the key and he's shown that's a boss
move saying okay I want white I'm only
going for the win Nothing Else Matters
wow
we're getting a big update right now
that there there was a misunderstanding
your demand for us misunderstood the
rules oh and he has chosen the black
pieces
it was a take back so he didn't lose his
money the sanity has been restored he
does start with nine minutes 56 seconds
on the nine minutes 53 seconds on the
clock and he will be playing with the
black pieces of Fabiano caruana with
white has to win on demand
that was unbelievable and for a reason
definitely unbelievable well now it's
exactly hold on here we go we got moves
a bit of spice add deferred steinits
from Jordan has been played against
Fabby before
and uh yeah this one you rarely see at
the top level fabi's uh as you say here
that Daniel got great experience here
but a bit of an older variation a bit of
an older line uh the Deferred steinits
rather than going for the classical main
lines rather than going for the Berlin
which seemed okay for him in the last
game Jordan he's gone for a slightly
strange setup here white has full
control over the center black slightly
cramped but black will try to break out
later back very very solid we should
mention and that suits him in a
situation where he just needs a draw
what do we think of the place so far
they've sped to this position Barely
Used 30 seconds each
what do we know about their Mouse skills
how good are they when it comes down to
seconds because the kind of Chess we've
been seeing from these two so far today
A Time scramble is expected Daniel I
think at this point Fabi is probably a
slightly better time Scrambler I mean
neither player plays a lot of bullet
online
but the way Jordan has handled this time
I'm really not worried for him right now
we've got a lot of traits if I be
playing the C4 variation which is a very
positional line you're trying to clamp
down on the D5 Square Jordan's sticking
a knight on D4
a bunch of minor pieces getting traded I
like fabi's position though that Knight
is going to move back to E2 Jordan
probably flirting with dtake C3 Exchange
sacrifice I don't believe in that though
I think he has to recapture D7
yeah just take back that white light
squared Bishop your Rook is hanging you
don't want to get uh kind of too bogged
down in the details here you don't want
to burn one or two minutes on your clock
calculating and there we go he
eventually does make a decision so we
talk about the bishop pair quite a lot
black has just got one Bishop now and a
doubled Pawn structure wow look at all
the pawns on the D file right now uh
whose piece is better here the Knight or
the bishop that's the big question I'm
definitely taking a knight here because
the bishop just doesn't have good
targets the bishop is pretty gross on F6
all it does is defend the pawn we do
have a target of uh even you know
eventually maybe a queen A4 not a mute
maybe now exactly immediately two Rook
fc1 try to massage those Queen side
squares get your knight back around to
C4 but okay but okay everything Pleasant
for weight very very pleasant for white
yeah we could well see an end game later
on of uh good White Knight against that
bad black bishop or we could see a
position as we keep seeing seemingly on
a day-to-day basis right now queen of
night versus queen and Bishop yeah again
every every time I don't know what's in
the air what's in the water
guy's doing what's in the air yeah
air quality is in the air for Jordan and
the quality of that Bishop matches the
quality of it puts the queen on C4 of
course the Knight would really want that
square but you know the price of a move
here isn't that high white is in control
here
that black Bishop has nothing to bite on
it staring at its own Pawn it's got
tunnel vision right now and it's not
liking where it's looking the White
Knight has beautiful potential still yet
to find a great square but if you pick
up that white knight and put it on any
light square around the center of the
board it's going to sit pretty for the
rest of the game it's going to
completely dominate Black's whole Army
yeah I don't like it for black I think
objectively three minutes down as well
James Ah that's correct I mean I even
have my own attacking chances F4 might
be a little bit too much so we can just
like relax here where she does Queen A2
and put the Knight on C4 now that's a
sick move Fabi with some nice Queen
Maneuvers in this match thus far
he just has to keep milking this
position he's kept a five minute time
Advantage Jordan
I think he's preparing to go D5 in
response to Knight C4 good defense here
thus far by the Dutchman
yeah he's doing all the right things he
wouldn't he just needs to play quickly
confidently and not allow any knockout
blows not allow uh Fabi to kind of post
up one of these positions
for Queen D5 I think I mean maybe now
also it's a multi-purpose move but I
like Queen D5 when I was a detour
because of rookie five so F4 now I can
play Queen D5 with maybe some Rook C5
hinting at or Knight C4 to follow behind
it put the queen lead with the queen
there he might have Queen E6 but I might
have Queen C6 so there's some little
subtleties here I think F4 was a really
nice move here if I go at five though it
might be pushing too much because now my
dark squares are extremely weak the
bishop has some targets he wants to go
to now I definitely like the F4 but now
we have to figure out what's the
follow-up maybe Queen D5 E5 is also
something that has to be calculated oh
yeah correct E5 six but that'd be going
very very positional
hitting this Pawn maybe he's asking the
queen to challenge and then he'll drop
into the D5 nope I'm hanging upon don't
do that Abby don't try that at all he
doesn't have to try that one and now
it's about getting this white knight
into the game okay going for the queen
trade Jordan will you trade Queen's Fabi
that is the big question I think I would
try to keep Queens on if possible but
even taking them off the board looks
very promising to me yeah Queen takes B7
and Knight C4 really depends on the type
of advantage that Fabby wants to have
does he believe in his ability to grind
out an edge in the end game Queen A2 is
possible that also looks like the most
tempting option for me you might get a
repetition of moves maybe Fabby can
switch his Focus over to the king side
after that you know I saw the bar react
as well and it suddenly made me think
maybe Knight jumping into C4 immediately
not worrying about the fact that the
queen trade will damage white structure
white might win a pawn wow that is
pretty sick maybe it goes Rook back to
oh yeah then dang that's nice 96 94.
maybe we show this because it could be a
key moment in this match the night
jumping forward hitting the Rook hitting
this Pawn the Queens are likely to come
off and at first it looks like Black's
Rook is going to get active hitting this
weak porn but white is the first to
start munching white could take this
Pawn you also have the option actually
of just going passive just defending
black is struggling in this position
strategically still because this bishop
is so bad and the white Knight's so good
it all depends I think fabi's
calculating this variation Knight takes
porn
I'm not sure where the Black Brook goes
to be honest and maybe jumping back the
more I look at this the more I think
it's very tempting for white it is Win
material
he's gonna find it this is a this is an
amazing spot here on Knight C4 and the
fact that he slowed down he's taking his
time he's calculating his way over
everything Knight C4 is coming on the
board
yeah when the top players pause you can
you know their instincts are kind of
screaming to them alarm bells are
ringing
and uh I think it's on his radar in ic4
at least he's going to work out the
consequences and decide whether that's
more promising than going for this for
example okay wow similar idea but not
winning a pawn directly at least but I
can understand it I mean F5 looks pretty
tempting here playing essentially on
both sides trying to induce weaknesses
that Knight on C4 is really pretty you
would kill to have this position in a
classical game but in an Armageddon game
you're gonna have to take some risks
here to ultimately break down Black's
very solid defense yeah the bishop isn't
visually appealing but it's defending
the D6 Pawn Jordan maybe preparing for
some active defense with that D5 Pawn
break we mentioned earlier
yeah Rook to B3 also comes to mind we
showed a similar idea earlier the black
Rook on the open defile sliding down
white only has one weakness really in
the position and that is the point
defending the White Knight so maybe you
can undermine that a bit later on
first how to deal with the advance of
white spawns Rook F3 yeah Rook F3
covering everything covering trying to
maybe double also some Rook G3 kind of
but I mean it doesn't really do that
much it feels like a useful move in
general that's just waiting
whoa okay all right couns they keeping
the status quo but no mix it up
what about ed5 and then F6 and try to
get that e file I'm a little bit
skeptical about that move I think Jordan
might have mistimed it White Knight off
to the elimination of the black pawn in
the center white tonight still sits
nicely on the C4 square look at the bar
the bar is like yo he's winning I'm
curious what's the line takes F6 Bishop
fa Rook D1 I guess but then Rook d8 you
can also just take D5 take G6 and go
rookie two to E6 I think Jordan's moves
looks good but it actually creates a lot
more problems than it solves we're
seeing it happen on the boat
and rookie six that's Unstoppable I
think Jordan is collapsing here from all
sides the A6 spawn also going to be
hanging this might just be lost I mean
from a few that was only like a few this
game hasn't even been going that long
barely started the end game they got
into this end game you think it's gonna
be a 50 move grind boom Jordan
cooperating by opening up the center it
only favored White
maybe Jordan should have taken the white
pieces
look how that night dominates both the
Rooks you want Rook B6 or D6 to stop you
from going into E6 you can't even go
King F7 literally my Rook is going to go
to E6 whether you like it or not that's
a very very strong uh configuration of
pieces also in the light squares look at
my pieces all in light besides the two
pawns On A and B but everything else on
light here Rook F5 that's a nice move I
see okay maybe just Rook E6 anyway
P6 don't you just win a bond yeah that
works too it was taking rookie six
simple
yeah we saw Fabi Flex the Fabi Flex a
few moments ago he was like yeah I got
this i got this and I think Tanya's
variation on the board King G7 Rook
takes E6 and maybe Rook B3 like you said
David Black's Only Hope yes to pin all
of his hopes on that D3 Pawn can He
surround it
I think the answer might be no things
getting even worse here
is this a tricky idea of trying to put
the bishop on C1 and Target those Queen
Side Pawn you really want to get to the
base of that pawn structure on the queen
side the B2 Pawn is Bishop C1 in the air
you might have to try it there's simply
nothing else either you resign pretty
much or you go for some active play and
we know Jordan loves his active play
yeah I think you're right Tony had that
black Bishop's gonna dive into the white
position and go Pawn hunting still looks
like it might be very slow in the
meantime maybe three of your points have
will drop for black but at least you
pick off the base of the pawn chain as
you say Tanya
gotta try it there's nothing else
simply cannot defend passively in this
position
there's absolutely no way to defend that
A6 Pawn Jordan looking for his active
defense here perhaps start marching up
with the king before he goes with the
bishop he goes for the idea targets
white spawned on the queen side the
problem is that there are so many
weaknesses for black the 861 will also
fall I love this move by Fabi ambitious
play keeping that a pawn and that's a
super dangerous passer for black to
handle just too easy for Fabi I mean
these are moves these are low hanging
fruit kind of moves right he can decide
between pushing his a pawn further H6 is
hanging I don't see a single source of
counter play for Jordan anytime he
attacks the D3 Pawn white can just slide
the king over to E2 and the Knight on C4
also controls the B2 Square so black
stroke has no active prospects Rook B6
there might be no black Rook at all
after the Rocks come off the board this
was this is essentially over yeah that
was clinical Rook B6 is so nice now we
just pushed the pawn through a5a6 you
can't stop I gave Rook B7 in and then
I'm just trying to Queen this Pawn
number one number two I can walk the
king I can play G4 at some point I have
all the play my Knight's great on C4
your Bishop's only defending H6 this one
is a clean win from Fabi if he's able to
convert yeah this is just a master class
in not allowing the opponent any
activity any counter play at all you can
tell on the body language from Jordan
he just uh feels no hope at all and he
that has been the case the whole game it
was a bit of a kind of a misstep in the
opening I think to allow this Knight
versus Bishop kind of Face Off and he's
paid the price
that White Knight has just been too
strong the whole game
and this really did feel like a
one-sided Armageddon this amazing play
by Fabi who needed to win on Demand with
the white pieces and uh he just never
gave any chance for Jordan run for us to
stay in control in that position and
right now we are seeing amazing
Precision in the end game as well a rook
trade is essentially lost but avoiding
it doesn't help as well the a pawn just
step-by-step marching down the board do
you see any chances at all for Jordan to
set up those tricks we've seen him make
comebacks in matches zero because all of
White's pieces are also on light squares
the king can move up to F3 that Bishop
is utterly helpless it's like having the
wrong type of screwdriver and you're
trying to screw something in once that
pawn reaches A6 everything is on perfect
squares and white doesn't even have to
promote that pawn white can just go
around and start mopping up the king
side pawns I think Jordan might be a
couple steps away from resignation I
would play Rook A7 A5 and try to bring
that King into F7 but all of that is
going to end up as a moot point
yeah this is going to be hopeless
threats already of Rook B7 threats of
the night jumping in winning pawns
everything is wrong and uh doesn't look
like Jordan is even going to continue
this game just to show a rook trade
doesn't help either this Pawn is simply
going to be too fast to promote a black
king way too far away
and we can tell by his clock usage as
well down now to three minutes
physically going to be hard to complete
this game even if you didn't have a lost
position
so Jordan he's had such a good run in
this tournament he's been so impressive
in such good shape such good form but
when you copper come up against Fabi
it's just another level
yeah and I mean the level was great
actually from Jordan even to make it to
Armageddon here but I mean Fabi just
brought out the best here blazing and I
think the order might have moved a
little bit too quickly that's it the
bishop actually is no squares Rook B7
wow maybe or just worked I would just
play Rook takes H6 right and I think
Jordan's gonna resign if he does that
playing without a rook The Rook is
totally incapacitated there in front of
the white Pawn there we go pawns on both
sides of the board the H Port is going
to start running soon
it's going to be game over and that
night on C4 has been the dragon in
White's position just keeping everything
under control and no chances for black
was that the hero in this Armageddon
one of the many Heroes the white Rook
has been no slouch either just
impressive piece King e14 D5 is the sort
of Russian Schoolboy approach yeah I
think that'd be if he really wants to
savor how winning his position is he
will delay the the moving of the G Pawn
G5
is begging to be played but if I be
slowing down I think we might see your
move down you're looking E4
now why Crown this Glory why promote a
pawn when you can advance with the white
King right look at that clock situation
seven and a half minutes for Fabi
oh I think he already knows it
yeah yeah heartbreaking tough
take place so well all right Fabby let's
get down to business there it is
I think this is resign time for Jordan
yeah look at the domination those pieces
on the most beautiful squares you'll
ever see in an end game this is the
definition of good night versus bad
bishop and
soon we'll be down at the good night
[Laughter]
and given another check just to make the
black king even more passive before he
goes spawn hunting and these are the
last few moments for Jordan run for stay
in the Chaska cup
Fabi with the lean back and just relaxed
and calm can you see the stands I'm
playing Abdus tomorrow
yep any move here wins you can take a
pawn you can step forward with the white
king you can maybe even just give a
night check there we go oh Bishop D6 A7
wow beautiful
that's going to end it officially
no way to stop the promotion just
clearing up the seventh rank for the
Rook so black king cannot step onto B7
just such amazing once again the full
board awareness by Fabi tactics
everywhere
yeah he's not resigned yet I thought he
was about to push that button
nothing to do what's going to make me a
queen
yep that's it that's it
Fabiano caruana takes the match against
Jordan man first and you can't see the
relief on a fabi's face it's been a long
day in the office for the American
Grandmaster taking the first match in
the Armageddon and there Jordan is such
a fighter it's a fantastic chess with
big upsets here in the chess kid cup
it's been so much fun to watch the
entertaining action that Jordan brings
to the board his creativity for today
facing Fabi at his absolute best was a
tough task from the start and David once
again a Flawless game there by Fabiano
caruana what's the big chess kit
takeaway moment a few big takeaways from
this game I actually am tracing Jordan's
big mistake to back in the opening it's
hard to be too critical but it was this
move that allowed the eventual
domination of the black Bishop by the
white Knights and here I think just a
trait of the wrong set of minor pieces
you to be so aware here ruining the
black porn structure as well in the
process black now is saddled with these
weak Pawns in the middle of the board
which actually persisted to the end of
the game and after a few more trades
here we did see that white knight which
eventually found a beautiful post on C4
compared to the sad black Bishop which
never got into the game just if we fast
forward to the final position to show
why Jordan van Forest resigned it was
after this night check still good night
versus bad Bishop if Bishop takes Knight
finally eliminating that beautiful seed
onto A7 and there's no way to prevent a
queen from appearing next move what a
game beautiful from Fabiana caruana
this amazing chest there and we do have
fabulous Fabi joining us from Madrid
Fabi congratulations
what a day of Chess this has been the
first match against Jules went down to
the Armageddon you took it in that one
there and this one as well do the wire
an absolutely Wild Ride how are you
feeling right now
yeah it's uh it's been a tough road to
get here but I'm very happy about it and
yeah today was a mixed bag but overall I
mean it's so so tough these short
matches and especially with two
armageddons that I'm I'm reasonably
um happy with how I played even though I
think against against Jewel uh the
second game was unnecessary I mean I had
a huge advantage and and basically no
risk and then I I blundered D3 and
suddenly I had to to fight in a very
complex end game which is not really
what I was aiming for uh but the the
armageddons were both very smooth so so
that was really where um where
everything went right today
yeah we thought all day your chest was
just super Moon just Flawless play in so
many games and Bobby I want to draw your
attention to one particular moment I
know you've played so many games today
but it was the game one with Jordan and
there was this really amazing sequence
of moves which ended with you
sacrificing your queen after the whole
night H4 uh tactical Skirmish how much
of it had you foreseen in advance when
Jordan went H3
yeah so when he played rookie three I
understood he was trying to trick me
but then I thought I'd try to trick him
in his trick by playing because I I saw
this Knight F6 which was obviously his
trick and I don't know if he finally
tricked me or
um or if he hadn't seen his H3 in
advance I had seen H3 but I didn't see
that he could trap my queen of Works
before I thought I just take the Knight
I put my king on h8 and uh of course
otherwise I would never go for this
because I was slightly better if I
hadn't gone for Knight H4 I mean I I
have no risk in the position so so
definitely there was no reason to go for
this but I still wasn't worried because
I figured like when I went down this
line I figured even if I blunder
something most likely I will be able to
suck my queen in some way and make a
draw uh and this is not a particularly
complex Fortress so I wasn't too worried
because very often there's fortresses
even when you just have a rook against
Queen but rook and Bishop uh is almost
always a fortress although I did see
that very recently
um
uh Boris girlfriend lost
Rook bishop and pawn against Queen and
two Pawn so that can be tricky but with
equal pawns I think it's almost always a
draw
so Fabi is it safe to say that you
believe in fortresses
we're still when did Magnus say this was
it like 2016 we're still we're still on
it seven years ago
uh yeah I do believe in some fortresses
you showed that to us uh in a Flawless
way today and uh Fabi you will be facing
not a back Abdul satrobe in the final uh
Grand final tomorrow looking ahead your
thoughts on that matchup
yeah I mean considering he has has two
lives I I guess I I am an underdog in
this match uh but if I if I get past the
first one I do feel like there's some
psychological Edge going going into the
second one although I do wonder about
this sometimes maybe it's a very
individual thing because some people
would
um
would let's say start to feel like
they're messing it up if they lose the
first match and that would tilt them but
sometimes if you win the first match you
feel like your job is done and of course
it's only halfway so that can also relax
you so so there's a lot of Dynamics with
the uh with the double elimination
format but uh of course I mean he has
two lives and he's been showing super
consistent chess it's going to be
really really tough and I would be uh
I mean I would be lying if I said I I
definitely don't I thought I don't feel
like a bit of an underdog uh to to win
two matches against him but I'll try my
best and I'm very happy to be here in
the final
Bobby it's a dream final we're so
excited to see both you and naughty back
fight it out tomorrow it was a fantastic
day of Chess and we had a fantastic art
competition and we had kids from across
the world sending uh drawings of all the
players participating in just get cup
and we've got one for you
I you know I saw these last night and I
couldn't I couldn't stop laughing for
like five minutes straight I was
cracking up
um I mean
mine is great I I do um I do want to
meet the kid who who who drew that
because it's I think that he has a real
future or or she has a real future and
uh and uh being an artist and Hospital
they actually win a one-year chess kid
membership so that's also good news
there Fabi will have that drawing sent
to you for sure it's but it's been
definitely a really heartwarming to get
all the entries and the winners of the
drawing competition uh Fabi
congratulations for today you get that
art piece and we'll see you back
tomorrow with the big fight against
nordeback
thanks see you tomorrow see you later
with a fantastic performance there uh
today winning against Jews and then
winning against Jordan One Forest and of
course there's been fantastic
performance all around in the Champions
chess store Simon what have you got for
us uh yeah a quick update on division
three but before we go there does he
really win that artwork
yeah that's gonna be Fabby really wins
the artwork you're gonna deliver it to
him that's going to be the best treat of
his life I'm sure I could see him
framing that on the wall in a really
good place in division three uh we have
a final now so the final is going to be
a match we've already seen once before
then it's going to be Harry Krishna who
beat the young player born in 2006
Dennis lazovic is going to have another
shot at Alan pitcho and the first time
these two played I did think that Harry
was favorite but Alan picho played
really well and got a nice trick in the
opening so this is a this is a rematch
another chance but let's remember as
Fabi also said there you've got to win
twice as the underdog because uh if you
haven't lost a match then you get a
second chance in the grand finals so you
have to say everyone who has the second
chance must be the favorite and uh Alan
picho performing really well brilliantly
thank you so much Simon for that and of
course you got big matchups coming up
tomorrow in all the divisions let's take
a look at our bracket going into the big
Grand Final of division one Fabiano
caruana what a day and it's not just the
score line it's not just going through
but the quality of Chess that is uh Fabi
at his absolute best and he will be
playing another player who has been
Unstoppable in the Champions Chester so
far in the Chaska cup not the back of
the statue off Daniel is that a dream
final it absolutely is listen it's not
alireza it's not Hikaru we thought that
they would last longer than they did but
two players who have shown the best form
and the most consistency thus far in the
Chaska cup are rewarded it's a Herculean
task for Fabi will have to beat Notre
back in two matches but if he shows the
same for me as this tournament he's got
a serious Fighting Chance James is their
favorite
yeah right now it looks like abusotura
because I mean he has the two you have
to be beaten twice right but I mean
fabulous Fabi has definitely showed out
and he lost one match and I was too
Abdul sotara so he's looking for Revenge
looking for Revenge chat who are you
rooting for
coming up the winner will punch that
ticket to the season final at the end of
the year there is Big drama tomorrow and
we are so excited to bring you the
action it truly is the dream final we
will see you there
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign